okay we're back yeah I don't know if it's go
back
alright so how do I get out here
I need to get coronavirus again
restore only crazy ass
Chrome by itself when my fan come on
all right so what do we got we have we have
something to do here
it is
all right let's do this let's do
a grits please work
I'll be sad if it doesn't work that's really
annoying
oh my God I know it's not working I feel so
stupid
Oh I took a reboot for me to figure this out
I feel so stupid anybody want to guess I
know it is now
Mississippi
anybody want to guess I'll give you a hint
why is that getting printed
so stupid I feel really stupid thank God
it's an easy fix all right
every single thing the reason yep
remember we we still had all this shit left
over I got I got I forgot I forgot that we
saw. That's what this was exported out and
see why this would come in and out yeah
I'm going to put a thing here so so here's
the vagrant thing right
play use this if you really want live for
Rochelle box that is not need
so it's like it's a comment
and yeah
it's a career to figure that out
I was like I'm changing to make if you keep
forgetting Baker it was even running on my
computer
strictly speaking it was regular doctor but
it was running in the doctor computer and
that's why I that's why
so yeah
if this means we need to do some stuff when
you kill these environments
exact bash National that should clean it up
affection set in Corinth
if that's how you feel I have to I have to
I got to make an update here are you like a
head smack emoji
when's the head smack it smack emoji
aunt
emojipedia
forehead confounded face where's the head
slap
I think it's called heads left right
fishing head getting there in his baseball
baseball baseball courses
horses baseball
she has to be here
alrighty
c'est la vie
set a why do you think I take notes some
people can make you cannot face the Kathy
what I'm doing
this entire problem
fine because I was using Docker image which
comes with Live Verse setup
how's that baby Grinch
command on my host system
so yeah
download mistake
it will now we don't know anything we don't
know what's real at all now we can't check
it
yeah I just feeling well
still says virtualbox right but I want to
test something here I want to unset
unsent vagrant file provider do you have
anger file
and we're going to set it oh I don't know
whether the father is so let's let's try it
vagrants up and its use the one in the Box
New York hours of ox it got it may I sit
down on the fucking image I don't care of it
LOL
yeah it's Susan and heresy is universal
rocks
now what if I don't Define it what's the
default on the system
I don't know that I could probably read it
but I kind of want to prove what it is so
what does some kind of that mr. It should
not be that then oh God
all right so test number one
come on finish up
I noticed it virtualbox takes a lot longer
than we have been hurting delivered I know
that last time too
so
is that one live right now
straight up puppy yes
and let's do
the export
I was it
let's do an explicit then I want to see what
the default is so
first things first let's delete this and
let's play.
Well I know we're going to 7.
I think it's your fault
it does it is ever so much better phone all
right so
destroy and I can use by default
and there is no environment variable
okay so that's important
so if you want to overcome the default
we have to we have to put it I don't hear
anything or did it which one wins if we have
the environment variables that the ritual
box and we have the internal set blood Verge
let's see if he can get it to change the
first of all
all right
we know this will break but I just want to
see if it's going to change it trying to
understand your behavior by breaking it
Measuring Up This should try up why because
I provided because this isn't a thing or
ignored it completely fucking ignore that
because of this
I think I do wear socks again all right
and that would be consistent with my
experience before
let's force it to be liver
the more of the story is it going to be at
least a document and otherwise just use it
out of the box and it'll default to
Oxon Hill the phone number to absolute true
cuz this is a crash and burn but it will
definitely force it to do the bird
yep Miriam cannot be found that's why we
haven't been able to so let me know need to
be darker and more of the story is you know
just install the default you're good to go
and now we were actually going to wait we
know
let's try storage now so we know that this
is doing the right thing
Things Remembered I'm set
we got rid of it right yeah
so that has no reference whatsoever except
that I am an explicitly put the bird in
there and just fucking ignored it so I'm
dropping the provider line completely and I
don't plan on using anymore
this reminder line is required though you
cannot provision
I don't know why me try me try again here
for some reason you cannot do when I'm about
to do it you can't do no. Memory
we tried this isn't work I want to try it
again now
cuz the hostname wasn't working either so it
might have been something else
yeah I'm just a mega morning about Negron
yeah it doesn't go there it's the strangest
thing you can't set CPU per machine as to be
per provider
I feel like the domain models broken on that
point
trying to ask if he ready for Eurasian
well you can't do that but I'm not trying to
when I when I do is I want to be able to
have
I mean I think I think I think I have to
have an entirely new one of these right
like if I if I wanted to have another one
I think I could do this
I think I think I can resist just as I mean
it I'm just I'm just fucking around anybody
think you've got anything here
and when do professor
ISO
I'm I'm I'm I'm a variant fan and now I'm
actually back to me you don't here's another
reason to do it is virtualbox even if we
have to pay for a little bit of you know
extra performance head and the annoyance of
maybe more bugs in virtualbox instead of
chemo the other recipes that I will be
usable on Windows and Mac and everything so
you know it's not going to be
I can be more usable thing across the board
so I think that's kind of the way to go
exactly the mainstream way to do it
I know that the people who do it on YouTube
video covid-19 could you come in a simple
structure
architecture and stuff they use they use
virtualbox provider usually from the Mac
actually there's a bunch of them they're
using Max for this and they just they they
run virtualbox on there and they do exactly
she didn't
so this is the same a Grinch
statues to shut two boxes up yep
fragrant shisha bar
and we should see memory here we we have
chicken memory
and swap it just wasn't needed and if you do
vagrants
huh they have the same
did I not change that
oh I change the fuse I just use that memory
all right talk
how do I do that it's is it see what is it
what is it
I think it is C yeah
a T or C is a t or c I can't you do it
I can send me some shoes.
CPUs
and this is why so that did work that works
that's nice to know you're safe and secured
for this though Contra what is I think this
is it
no it's not
seeing you want colors colors yay
I can't remember what it is
there's one that shows
Kat proxy p.m. is probably better and yeah
thanks guys there is something to do you can
do the top though
yeah it is cheap it's too serious that's it
but that's naked with a reminder that's what
that's a much better way to do then it's
also available everywhere
Galaxy View did not know about that one
did not know that Alan
it's only wants to do what the fuck oh
that's bar
so stupid CPU still only one Seaview
lettuce and Inspire confidence
I know it's going on more now but I still
pisses me off I still have not figured out
how to provision different size mediums in
vagrant and that seems like a really basic
task and I have no fucking idea to do so
yammy both of these words this definitely
worked
but
no it's not one no that's the version of the
API unfortunately
I think I think that is actually imperative
in other words we could do
let's try this I think we could do this
I don't know but I think you can do this
that's right
do CPUs and then you can change it I think
it's again I think it's imperative that I
think you can say okay now I want
run CPU do the rest
again I'm still traveling are right I wish I
could read with reading takes so long it's
usually wrong
I mean the proof is in the pudding I am more
likely resource go that I have documentation
I am it's just because cuz the dogs are
always so wrong not always a gamble but
In-N-Out so yeah
oh wait are you guys getting the wrong Mike
I'm sorry about that I just noticed you're
getting the wrong Mike
and nobody said anything cuz you were so
nice to me every time I reboot I have to go
change my bike back to the good mic
it it always recesses stupid fucking thing
they're about that much easier on your ears
I imagine
it was horrible yeah I still works but it's
just really bad
yeah quite a difference huh
yeah well I know how I really sound before I
go through a nice soundboard
I'm going on the foo
Ella CPU just one just want to see if you
this is the new oh and you follow because I
better sound thank you for that
hey can you do an official
I do not see a change and I'm I'm kind of
annoyed not annoyed or either documentation
nf3 the doctor today
God damn it what am I doing I want to see if
you
there's only one on there my mother is a
Multiverse I don't know what multipass is
what is multipass
are asteroids ever told by Joanne Sis's fuck
now talk now
that's in a bunch of only thing and I'm
using redhead I need 200 for lunch a person
machines
because if I do laundry machines there's a
kind of new kid on the Block multipass
I did
hey I need to be a manager of blood look no
further than canonical's multipass will ya
that would be a hard pass
so
what are we doing here this is a fail my
test is a fail this
did not I do not know it seems like it reads
the first one and that's it
anime say something I'm going to change the
first one to use one
ignorant and Tate welcome it's a hobby
welcome
that's not a thing destroy I kind of want
dinner I'm hungry
destroy bar and Destroy food please are you
going to
miles fast why you taking so long
wait what when that farting farts booting VM
who look it made me a storage
Runner storage who key inserted
ask me another one my fan just came on
yes I am that's exactly what I'm doing yeah.
Just to learn
yeah. Just to learn it but sit with the shit
out of it cuz I need to test them
applications at work
you can't do that with Medicaid so it's the
best it's the best way to test Community
work in my opinion
I do not answer I know it is but it's just
storage bar right so it makes me wonder
I don't know where it's at me vagrant status
I was going to rush my son there vagrant SSH
who
they should both only have one CPU oh you
know what
last time both of them only had one CPU yeah
so the last one wins people all right good
to know
yeah watch if I change
the bottom one to two it'll make it to even
do this one cuz whatever's last winds even
if it comes before that means this this
thing is not processed in any type of work
at all it's not it's not processed in order
except for maybe maybe this stuff like I
think it does this this before this going to
take if your provision one thing before the
other it'll do the one after the other one
because it's in the same block I have a
feeling but if it's not in the same block.
So and I probably I probably understand that
if any reveal the better
so we on if I do this destroy
yes yes yes please
how's it going free Karina
I want to send for me but I don't know which
language start with that is a very personal
decision I have done so many videos on that
none of which the best of which is not with
us anymore because twitch it depends on what
you want to learn
if you want my opinions on what to learn
first maybe watch the Boost it goes through
that I'm very unpopular opinions is so if
you want to be empowered and then learn
JavaScript
becoming data structures first that would be
better than the Yamaha that yellow Jason it
depends what kind of career you want to
write
it's like asking what programming language
you should learn is like asking which Hammer
you should learn to use or which saw you
know you're asking to use a tool but you
know it's a tool
you know like it's it's
so it's hard for us to answer the question
because we don't know what you want to build
I want to put a crown molding do you want to
know it or not he's balking have a really
well yeah because you got to get any of
those little tiny cracks
I want to I want to I want a frame houses oh
well you probably want to use a nail gun but
it but if but if you don't use a nail gun
you probably want to get old clawhammer seen
him saying you need to know what you want to
build if you just want to learn how to code
IE I just want to know how to use hammers in
general that yeah I get a claw hammer is
going to have the most utility
across-the-board right right and so I went
learn pausing shall personally I would learn
bash first and then I would come back and
learn politics after that and that's a
change an opinion on my part from visiting
the last 2 years passing shell is very
dangerous for taking it for beginners so I
strongly encourage you to learn actual bash
unfortunately there is no good material on
how to learn magic after the bathroom and
Paige
everything that teaches bash does it
completely wrong and unsanded unsafe way and
I can justify that statement and have
because it doesn't double if you're going to
look for his promise me this if you're going
to learn to show us her first and you going
to do it make sure you don't do anything but
double brackets and double front to seize in
your end know the difference between double
brackets in the performances and don't mix
the two and use those in Bosch uniquely
never ever use a single bracket if you don't
understand why study the difference and
you'll understand immediately why
ringer SSH tunnel professional could I just
wrote you today and it was like all of the
fucking completely insecure totally and
Shell Shocked on yourself
run shellshock I personally if you want it
if you want an overall you know Hammer
that's going to work for everything it's
going to make you good at everything I think
learning bash as a scripting language is
very valuable because it goes with the
terminal right now used to travel a lot so I
can make I can make all kinds of magic
happen and then that the next most important
language after that to me is go because go
is a very very generic language that is very
very highly performant that has garbage
collection which makes it was simple to
write language to but my son is very very
bad for beginners because zeeshan Bachelor
cover that a lot Bashas the default shell on
Millions if not trillions of systems in
seashell is the default shell on Apple
because Apple doesn't want to deal with
gplv3 that's the truth so special is it far
far inferior shell The Bash on every level
and I can prove it this show will also get
you in big big
I will because it tries to do 14 point
mathematics where as it uses the plain old
positive she'll syntax and positive shell
does not do floating-point Matt so Sam is
going to copy and paste Jersey shellcode
into when I get out scripting right if you
want to use the show for interactive shell
that's fine I don't really have an opinion
on that
I just wish his usual every time I open
Terminal you know why because they because
they don't want to fucking pay the money and
they don't want to deal with you if you feel
that is the only reason yeah it's the only
reason
vagrant diseases did Apple once gplv3 to die
and I agree with them but for different
reasons than one thing and I regret the most
of the badges that is CP3 it is my single
greatest regret but I have to use it because
it's just so fucking powerful and it's the
default
it's going to be p.m. all right let's do
food now if we did this right both of them
should have to see fuse yep
even though yep they both do
all right so that confirms something for me
there
these stanzas right here are not like this
one and then this one right whichever one is
last wins
and you cannot change it you cannot change
it for the life of
you can't change it for the life of the of
the thing
so it's kind of annoying actually
but I accept it girls Google that's not true
at all
yeah people are people who say that don't
know anything about go I appreciate that it
what you say is very popular thing to think
but it has no basis in reality or fact go
hasn't been associated with Google other
than people at Google or working on it for
more than probably 8 years
yeah if you're frightened of yeah
so yeah so yeah no goes
the entire fucking kubernetes world not to
mention all of Docker is written in go do
you think if they had any concerns of any
being owned by Google that the entire Docker
project would have created the most
substantial project
within the last two decades was written in
go
and they didn't do it while they were Google
it if they had had any concerns about it it
would have come up
yeah so I don't people think that Ruby is
independent and it's going to keep him safe
and everything and then they have massive
security vulnerability that they just fixed
finally in the last released and yet it's
run by a ton of people who an entire mod
team just fucking up and quit because they
have disagreements what would you rather
Tire cart to
a language that once was created in the
bowels of the most highly intensive
performance-driven concurrent see required
in an Enterprise on planet Earth or one that
was some accidental you know a thing up from
some guy at Mozilla that can't believe it's
gone and blue and
he was gone and it has this this this
completely
volatile community that then that
did you just freaking drink it away. You're
not you're not do your research so I'm not
mad at you I'm just saying do your research
before you make statements like that Google
go Google frightens me too but they don't
have control you if you want to be afraid of
Google be afraid of fuchsia
fuchsia something that's going to but they
do fully control they're trying to release
it and Samsung there and controlling them
now fuchsias the new like embedded device
operating system and that were given full
control of the operating system of most
Micro Devices and that you should doesn't
have any to Pier 33 in it so I would
actually want to use it above some of the
other leg stuff as well although Alpine
doesn't have anything and it Ralph on some
containers
yes on topics like I'm easily distracted by
the suffix I feel offended by my strong
statements in a feminist opinions I'm not
attacking you okay not attacking any person
here
bring up Wikipedia it was designed by Rob
Pike let me give you a homework okay
A Go-Go was created by three of the most
significant software designers and engineers
in history including the creators of Unix C
and unicode
name one other language on planet Earth that
can ever claim that
the only language on planet Earth I could
ever even come close to claiming that is see
which was created to make eunuchs
and you know it wasn't some accidental
project that maybe Firefox use one day
yeah I am I just understand once you
understand who rob Pike is
and you understand that Rob pipe work for
Google because that was the best player that
was that was his best alternative to Bell
Labs you'll never
I hate guys like Dennis last miles would say
things like I'm interested to go cuz Rob
Pike and that's like the only reason
50 Cent just cuz he knows how significant
bike is cell
can I people that like that I talk like this
and I apologize if I've offended people but
it's like
people make decision if you make decisions
based on the latest YouTube or twitch or
read it rent and you don't actually read
about the history and if you go to Wikipedia
is your sources of knowledge in the universe
you got a problem
and it's not you that has a problem it's
people that have the problem son it's not an
attack
but you know dig deeper dig deeper ask
yourself what is it used for and who uses it
and why but that will start with that ask
yourself that same question about rust or
python or any other language and by the way
you got it based got it's got to be on what
exists not on what is planned plan stuff
that doesn't exist call vaporware and
there's a ton of rust vaporware right now
I can't wait to see Channel if it's one of
your parties can you make beside the web
server
are you asking like to give you experience
no glow I expect that's what you're asking
I know you're asking for
hey we still don't have two drives
going to Fantastic Four anything on the
terminal I used to say that as fast as the
web interface is come out libraries go in at
Terminal applications come out anything goes
most powerful thing is it's concurrency it's
drop dead simple concurrency and its
batteries included from scratch
containerization potential that's why I go
dominates the entire class called native
world
and it completely dominates it
if you want to do something really
substantial and go write a container right
find some use for a container and write a
container that is from scratch using go and
you'll understand why goes the darling of
containers you get a 1.5 MB container
you can't do that with any interpreter
language because they have to have a full
fucking Linux OS in order to even runso as
in order to even run
yeah
I am frustrated by this because this should
have permission to discs in it did not so
I'm still missing some Basics here and I
don't know what they are and I'm going to
step away from a bit I will be back but if
anybody can help me figure this out all I
want is I want to disks that's it
I just want to provision 2 discs containers
Dockers were containers started but Dockers
really not the death
Docker containers in kubernetes I can't help
it you won't fully appreciate go and tell
you I appreciate the intricacies of
cloud-native computing containers and
kubernetes container orchestration when you
understand all of that stuff the value of go
just shoots off the page at you because you
see that how well IT addresses all of those
issues
alright so I was nice taking a nice little
message from my manager
I love my new manager he's awesome
he's awesome he's a real hands-off manager
just let you do your thing and produce value
in already it has benefited because we have
already been able to arrive at some
solutions and direction for the team
anything specific that we're working on
building because of that sort of
intellectual freedom to think about stuff
it's been really fantastic I really love it
busy there for two years and had my hands
hurt for using Kodi but my hands hurt from
using for task force is work
I've no idea how to how to help you
I rarely able to use them anymore I add
where I can Vin don't match
yeah I don't know what to tell you I really
can't if your hands hurt it's probably cuz
you're using mechanical keyboard instead of
a low-profile keyboard
that's the Medical Science on the issue
nobody wants to hear it but that's the truth
the Medical Science on the issue is High
Travel mechanical keyboard no matter how
clicky and smooth those blues and reds are
is medically unsound for you long term even
if you split it out and everything else go
do the research do your own research don't
take my word for it the best keyboard for
you is a low travel
low travel keyboard if you want to split it
up fine but it low travel keyboard membrane
keyboard won't let me go if it's a Memory
keeper you probably probably better off
I just went over the first disc you think so
is that your guest list right out
it's because I'm using to try dr.sun that
looks cool
that looks really cool that's cool thank you
for bringing it to our attention
holyshit holyshit
that is awesome
add create
that is super cool
give me a chance to get VIP today for
contributing something really awesome to the
Stream
I found out the VIPs rotate so whoever if
you contribute something really awesome I
have no problem giving you a VIP
specific specific for name of the first I
think let's try that and see if you ever
hear anything to back that up or is that a
hypothesis I'm all about the hypothesis but
fragrance destroy oh boy
where'd you find that
Vigor for multiple discs who who this is
awesome
you know I wish pastebin had a raw version
you should learn to that you should use
eakes my friend if you Zeke's it's be a lot
easier to get it
I want to do our acrevalue tills
oh this is like a ruby file
holy shit is amazing I need to start
spending time like reading all this stuff
but I haven't done it Hi how are you okay or
why are you stressed I need to I'll take a
break and we'll take a break here to take to
take a break so I can
snow tonight
you did I would like to eat some chili and
talk to you everybody I'm taking a break
listen to the music will be back by
I need to change that to
I want chili
like I know the mic is on thanks
back Payback I didn't get it it's raining
outside like bad
I'm going to get a snowstorm here pretty
soon
alright what are we doing
hey where am I check one two
that's weird music that word level
hi
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
specialized cuzzy controllers
a gun controller time check one two
check check check check check check check
Chetek toxic workplace by becoming toxic
I don't know this is hard
I have no advice on that I am a horrible
person
task that suicide
Jerry Martin adapt and overcome that's like
one way to put it I guess yeah
yeah I I don't know the answer honestly
don't I'm not trying to dodge the question I
honestly don't know
all right
what are you going to be going to try to
make bigger and bigger do a VM box
local this formative file name size
and port how do you report for local disk
for Sky of
virtual virtual iOS device cousin controller
Rene descarte this is interesting
I just recognized file as you want to be
ignorant
okay so difficult here before before up oh
wow you can do trigger cool
before up at Sugar Creek Disc trigger
Robidoux
make a file directory local disk c h the
local is file name equals
how much rain does the rectory double desk
vdi
whose phone is this press creating local
disk system
look at that he box manage great medium file
wow that's cheating
this is totally cheating
you feel insulted yeah well it's a journals
this is definitely true that you're cheating
I like it a lot but I feel like it's
cheating
containers in my vagrant oh my vagrant huh
adem that looks really cool
oh my vagrant looks really cool
this looks really cool
super interesting
the American public is easy way we strapped
to them if I read please for speeding up
heart rate number of us when she's a bigger
without writing Ruby code yay
four multiplication cater to him until maybe
we can be used to help this happen when
actually can we hurry this was a darker
application development environment I made a
quick lesson of my screen catching topic
he went to the street this is fucking
awesome
where did this come from this is 7 years old
and he's been doing if I refuse to Baker
with puppy doctor more
oh my God this is Olivia. Uses of Port
Authority and useful
yeah for sure I figured
see the jobless is more of a bigger puppy
dog haircut rename it
I have a problem with it is I want to I want
to have everything I can publish
if I do this I can't publish it no
I got stuff in my tea
I like it it's yeah well though
I'm going to Colin's I don't get that at all
I'm not running Doctor stuff in there
I'm not running Doctor stuff in there I'm
running communities
I'm running today so they can match
communities that summary I hate it that says
it has to do a system call Ali McMahon age
damn all right
now
yeah I can buy for destroy
I asked you this issue though this is a this
is a very interesting reference
you can't you can't do the kind of make one
disc pretty young it doesn't let you make
another one so
I even that I don't know that it actually
does I don't know then let you actually
build it bigger
if I think this is completely ignored say
the truth if I put 20 gigs here
all right vagrant destroy
migrants up
I'm in this happens
maybe machine boot 2222
vagrant private key access
SMS to call
alright I still have a senior recruiter
I said Rob
phone number to the thumb Knicks off a low
sodium
we can do people vagrants status
running virtualbox Now is it going to have
the extra disk space so we had 20 GB
we're going to see
nope it's not is what I don't understand
it gave it 16 GB of
said something about my dream assignments is
totally failing and I don't know what
David 70 GB
why would he give it 70 gigabyte of disrupt
bias
it's going to be I don't think it's I don't
think that disk line is working
I don't think it's working instituted
vagrant disk space
recombinant it's been around for a 50 GB
disc size that size
why would we understand plugging disc size
I said 2018 I used to be complaining regular
sizes ring sizes
is it true that a box of Eurasian studies a
would-be I asked him if a provider
it does how come and ask you in the provider
and let me just being completely ignored
I want to see this creation yes
all right I got to read the whole provider
thing for virtualbox
it's supposed to say I don't think it's a
delivered this issue has arisen box issue so
yeah I do have a spare The Faults of his
true
I would like a stranger I can customize a
name we got tied up game
and then end Nick type of fault linked clone
project lunch boxes Red Sox's recent large
overhead is that in front of Russian space
ceiling Coast Guard rescue soda
I think clowns are basically on a massive
you in Siri fighting in front of the base
box only once with four sides right lane
closed only the only difference difference
in disk images that are created when a
parent disk image like the master game
I'd rather do a link coronavirus through and
try that
all right a compatibility with a box do blah
your conversion there as well
just get the checks
to call any communication device matter just
prior to breeding the machine so it says
interesting
so you can do a bunch of stuff to a box
5 a.m. excuse again that's nice is it again
two beauties
X2 are you sure Siri is a few yep got that
all right with us again that is it how do I
search
I sent a message to Sam host anywhere
private sync folder
that's nice God damn that's nice
that's a fantastic Reagan file
Richard Marx to customize modify p.m. I need
to pick yes name hose params
G memory frenzy fuse customize storage CDL
Annie
oh she has this customized that means it
runs before the customer stuffs runs before
the meeting runs
say controller add second controller as file
exists
f e d i v a customer's create HD full name
holy cow
or is it a chain that is attached to the
storage nice that's why I'm out of him
that's cool okay yeah they should know how
to do it now
at Eyeglass World yeah yeah yeah Travis
to set up NFS over vagrant
okay if they are private Network friends IP
National 9 shell provision
s m s fig is there such thing they said the
whole thing without using the forever you
can do through the primers now
service APK. And for the Lazarus are pretty
popping on there
puppet do provision puppet do
oh I'll give that you can put it on there I
think that's Super Bowl sold but it's cool
probably just yes
I'm actually going to skip all that stuff
for now and I
a practice and if it's this for trash I
don't want to do this anymore
is it pretty clear that it does not raise it
sell
I mean that that's why I did that lab so I'm
going to remove it because I don't I learned
everything I need to do. I was comparing
provider storage and I I loaded everything I
need so learn did
episode back to where we were we were doing
so
is that going to work so nothing there
I just deleted it yep what the hell
is that the only internal
gesso lab vagrants
Freddy's they got the Focus engine
alright so back to where we were
nice so
and what are we doing here right
who did you choose to do
all right so we've got we got our verify
I'll just go ahead and set up an FS on this
thing we don't have to learn anymore we
switch back to the original box and we got
rid of everything else is a few things will
run but you can't add more than one disc at
this this thing is actually ignored as far
as I can tell this entire just fine is
totally ignored
and I'm kind of want to prove that
again I've already done it once but I just
want to pray it again
alright so
vagrant
yeah
this is just one
how's it going I'll blow
I think I'm going to think if I was going
inside the NFL stamp from scratch we are
going to eat with a new volume though it's a
problem we need we need a new volume
I keep going back to that I'm going to need
a new volume I can't do an offense on the
same mate in baseball and that just doesn't
work
or does it I was
I mean I suppose I could sit well let's see
let's see if I can set up an FS full amount
on a subdirectory of
the the control plane which is a bad idea if
I never do that in real life but
the ideal way to do this is set up a
separate his to set up a separate separate b
m b r i a separate separate volume and then
melt that volume to the VMware instance you
know but I don't know how to do that through
of Africa through vagrant we've looked at a
couple things that do that
in a couple things that do that
I just think you have to set up a controller
and all that stuff so I don't know how easy
that is to do
so this thing is just the central block that
the thing I can say about this is
that the
partition is 128 cm3 wonder where this
information is coming from
like how what what kind of volume separation
do I have in vagrant from the underlying OS
and I feel like
at this is like an arbitrary assignment you
know
I don't need I want to figure out how to
tell to change the base
to do that like why is it 17 gig why does it
to sign something to this is Sylvia and
partition in here
and why is this the eighth what is the base
what is a base disposition to have 128 gig
I mean and put a put a timer 27 for this 670
and then it's as it looks like it's leaving
out another 50 to 60 or something like that
they're like a ton of that extra disc that
we can probably partition
and I I mean that's like is arbitrary a
bouquet the base image
oh so that was built into the image right
well I think it's interesting is that the
images build is it sda2 so
based on this I should be able to allocate
another Mount point
so-so Simpson
yeah tell me why I switched virtualbox
because I thought I thought it was going to
allow me to Mount volumes easier than
Lindbergh
the ones that did finals the the final
yeah
well people are saying as much a bugs in it
real the real thing they converted me over
to this was the ability to mount volumes
and that is not possible liver at least not
easily it's not most important in a lot of
ducks on it because I want to test an FS
so this my current goal is to get into Fest
in my career is close to her and the number
away through the original way I was going to
do it as add a new disc at a disappointment
and which apparently has to be done in a
trigger in a hurry up trigger in vagrancy
have to run like a cyst call system call
against a merchant box call
how lions are mounted in a yes yeah well it
appears to me that
Ben 10 in the second possibility is I don't
even need to do that because there's already
been enough Rogers space allocated that's
free and that's what I'm looking for right
now
cell
right now it looks like there's a tongue
that there's there's plenty
idiot Center Fest it is Danna fastest
fastest legal
the vagrant mozzarella Fest you think it is
I'm interesting to know
here's here's a okay so here's a confusing
thing if I knew lsblk vagrant is showing way
interesting numbers here so I don't went and
told you this get to 92071
then one goes to boot the end of 2017 this
is only got 70 gig allocated so that means
that there's you know some 50 GB
unallocated storage in the SD to Partition
are you sure there are no pretty freaking
fix on the DM I don't know I don't know I
have to go look at it at the VM
have you met current thing and I wouldn't
know about hugging
I think it's the same one we already read
yeah this is a different when you have to
put the plug it in there
this is disappointing I'd rather not do this
I was just reading this one this is using a
I want to exhaust the possibilities without
adding a plug-in and this is just changing
the size it doesn't add a new volume this is
different far as I can tell
I just decided resizer
tell me what I'm missing here there's a to
me it looks like there's a bunch of discs
leftover that's on allocated and it just
doesn't seem to show that right off the bat
70 gig we what am I missing here so
I mean I can't I can't hurt my heart it
better if this is so
at the point is something sa-20 that's what
I
she's a memory 08
this is not the kind of thing you could do
without her it is not eating anything
and this is the danger most dangerous
command in all of eunuchs more dangerous to
DD in my opinion
I checked one command and you fuck
everything
there's a partition table you too
custom path
I don't think so. For the VM
I can't remember which one it is I thought
capacity
list free list free on produces face yes
that's the one there I thought so
see there's a ton of fun for Titian space
here
this image has a ton of unpartition
discounted was just weird to me
so
70 out of 128 gig
I see here I was just USDA and see what
happens
children's is a colonel thing The Ruck to
send the send files to self today really
I'm not aware of that
the partition 12 ac2
started in sectors and 27 gig
1 gig start 1024
2048 goes to this and this goes to this are
you ready
I guess so
I think it said there's a bigger generated
image I think it is yeah
direct me to the socket oh boy
reggae is pretty sure there's no protective
over here by Jennifer block now
did you have to use a VIP ticket is that it
or a bunch of us our allocation again
yeah yep
yeah I was just I was just what I'm thinking
it is I think it's that but it's it's it's
it's a VM version of it here locally this is
Guy. So why do I care because
I mean I've already burned up 170 128 GB
SanDisk for this disk image as far as I know
as far as we know it now and here's the
other thing is like what is the host of us
look like
Alexis for my mail so I have this Kinfolk
space info
this is true to I don't I don't know any of
those commands so virtual
box what are we doing this
it's is reporting 78 but it's not using all
seven again right
a boy how do you spell running
how many days are running
Christmas 2048 single CPU
I need to stop that one
power off
configure just file
well I mean
Megan is going to be unhappy because I'm
killing everything yet
they're dead Jim
I'm not using the word anymore
aunt alright so
all right so the one what's the goalwhat's
the goal here the goal here is I want to
mount a different storage volume
and I don't know how
normally would never do this I would have to
just find that I want an extra disconnect
have to create a different controller and it
had it
even through the graphic interface I don't
do that very often the disc metafile
yeah that's what we're looking for a problem
I'm running out of energy
yeah this is going to be useless useful
actually I did this I did this stuff
I tried this discussion is this Cassandra
yeah decide if you do for me
yeah I had this exact thing and it doesn't
work
so I mean I have it but what I don't
understand is how it doesn't show, shows
differently you're saying it's at the bottom
of that
I just meant if I both built into sections
if you're just in clean up this respect. I
just meant if I was inside a machine data
directory
so I was supposed to say we were keeping
track of the last if your state for Des
I just waiting for my Baker for keep track
of it just to be measure I think that's a
reminder uses
that doesn't accidentally delete or men is
just what they were configured outside
records there's advice provider
going to the end yeah they just failed to
see what this work to figure out on the last
run a bigger
a at the curry figure say something about
the current run an errand
I don't really care about the size and
already created filed his I don't care I
just want an extra volume as soon as he's
just your ID I just need it for you if it
notices there's no longer than her file, I'm
glad we read this because some of the other
just sand get home that get around this
there's vietnews were too much directly and
there's no way maker knows about that
there's no way
dude I mean vagrant doesn't know about all
of the Hooksett other Solutions are doing
their there the other vagrant options than
out there that you know that get just as
they exit out of vagrant
my using the system which is a thing
apparently in you can put in your bigger
files in the Ruby and then it runs it does
the volume and then attach isn't the reason
I'm leery of it is because it's all outside
of ignorant and this is one of the reasons
I'm concerned because because they got has
this this pedophile which gives it a notion
of what it what belongs to make her and what
doesn't within the Russian boxer better so
to me I really don't care about resizing
though that's not the goal here in the goal
here is I I want to add him as a going to go
here as we want to be able to add
another volume so that I can use that volume
as a while. How's it going how's it going I
do the provider config hash ringing. I was
worried about you better make her an easy
way to keep track and find this information
about this seems to be ignored and I don't I
don't know that it's true I'm still trying
to figure that out so if we if we go to the
vagrant file
are those who destroy just we are using
vagrants to provision a baseline collection
of machines that are prepared to be
kubernetes nodes so that
we can then use it to practice and selling
kubernetes and learning communities eating
on kubernetes until you know dies in to see
what we can we can make a type in different
glorious ways and is a couple things so this
here
what why does it say can figure in provision
in this is known for the information
I have to Texas right now cuz I justdestroy
I want to shut all those games out I can't
believe how bad I'm going to be a running
that I had not turned up so something about
they going to learn the hard way
the bigger up-down destroy status only show
stuff from your current directory I do I
defuse the global Dash status and which you
tell me what just showed me
because that'll give you all the vagrant
stuff on this machine so as you can see we
have multiple servers here
I'm going to just destroy with careless
abandon yeah
yeah I just tried it
yeah there's there's virtualbox things out
there for the response reminder I didn't
have to bring some extra better anymore
which makes me you know
wonder what's up yeah I mean I could
this is me trying to get the other stuff out
vagrants status yeah I was afraid of this
I can't do it unless he's a doctor container
yeah I'm going to have to like really ripped
that shit out because I switched back from
using the document energy is liver to the
over two boxes works out of the box and
calling it a day
say yeah yeah it's okay move stuff for that
yeah yeah I got it I'm going to try this out
he was a different thing I'm going to throw
away that lab I'm thinking of it cuz I don't
want to confuse people
I think I want to see something. Grade your
token it is delete delete love ignorant
g h delete is it RN or delayed
there is
yeah why just not there anymore
404 in one came and I destroyed an entire
repo
oh hahaha
I had to make that Commando cuz they're like
oh no we're not giving you that command
unless you ask for it make your own because
we don't trust anybody
is really great for like dreaming dreaming
all your you know retrieve photos of stuff
yeah if you want that file I'll give it to
you it's
config g h fig
that's the one
yeah here it is right here until it's not
that hard of a thing you just have to
is that the upgrade your token to use it
alright so
and with that we will now destroy all the
other stuff
on purpose
all right so so what's so remember to box
again
and if I bring a box power. Power. Power off
how about we delete your ass
delete all files cuz why not he's running
Windows
by the way if you want to know if you can't
use of yourself of course yes I do
it's a good thing about me 10 what's my
school education why is it seems like that
including my about me tab
do I have kids I do have kids and I also
have education
yeah I kind of feel like it's irrelevant
though yeah
I'm not one of these people who puts father
you know admin or whatever in their Twitter
because they think that makes him a better
person that I don't fall into that camp
my semester is about me and it's not so much
about my family and my family comes into my
stream that's I talked him a lot and so
that's why
at you want if you want me to Mercy and
click on my CV to have that is in there and
you could come and get home there's my CVS
have Anna has every fucking detail about
everything I've ever done so it's not like
I'm trying to you know
I didn't you want to go back and see
everything I've ever done
delete all files
I don't have who I currently work for them I
would never put that in the resume I think
that's bad form I think talking about where
you work is is tacky actually just do it's
one thing to give you more information about
you or your work place I think unless you're
being paid to Market where you working now
if you want that just got to make it home
yeah I'm on that to over there by that stuff
I mean yes
yeah but both my kids I have talked it turns
out it turns out that
my stepson is covid and both of both of my
sons are in college right now both of them
have called out covid
I just found that out today by the way I
found out today they told me 20
one of them is the one who had his head run
over by a Ford F-150 while sledding
I worry about him so much but I do know I'm
kind of out of their life but I hated that's
true I don't like that's why I don't talk
about it I just don't talk about him
yeah it's a story for another day I have a
really hard time talking about that story
and my Christmas time though I usually tell
her I didn't this year
is it it's actually a really Faith promoting
story and I I I I do and I do I do I am okay
sharing it
but it's not about me it's about my my
youngest son who I hardly ever
get to talk to her do anything with now
because Ben but I occasionally I'll I'll
hear him chat or something in an RN or
Discord
yeah I mean it's it's it's kind of a
I think of that it's kind of a to me as a
very faithful morning story Chiefs history
that's good yeah
imagine a lot I do a lot I just don't it
doesn't necessarily all the time right
Anna
some people said they just want to stream
all that only you know I was just talking
and shooting the ship which I don't love to
do but I got you know so much to do that
ends up do I end up doing that in the middle
of my other work streams like right now
how many kill this to die die die
yeah I'm I'm really wondering how the
provision of the Fest and I could totally
sheet and just Mount and mount mount the
control the control planes disc as the NFS
disc and then put a sub Mountain there
killing a man I can be yes it definitely got
me I agree
so here wealright so here we go
let's start over so the first thing I want
to know is if this isn't going to work now
going to change it to know none of the
information
say something so I want to check that Civic
wrench
Google status I'm hoping that stuff is all
gone apparently not
I didn't know such a prune invalid issues
with any of the machines you can go to the
director for The Runaway car or you can use
the ID directly with Vigor commands for in a
dream
okay figure and destroy you
and I thought I was pretty that
was not found was not found configure for
The Singing River
I had a feeling I got any like isolated Big
Ring completely now
and I don't know that looks like I'm going
to go look at some stuff here so I'm going
to go see if it posted stuff in my dog can
take some place
I assume so no.
That vagrant. D is a thing and you're hungry
trees
he said p.m. sister here exactly ring a
sledgehammer
boxes data gems
die die die because I want to see the death
the death of ignorant on my system
Rainbow Dash r f Todd vagrant let's see what
this does
what if I pull this out important
name that movie or movies actually
so what have we actually done here
after a current death rate in Canada super
sheet
show me a dance or something
goddamn goddamn god dammit
enter my keys I got to know what the fuck
I'm doing all right let's do this
shall we try shall we play a game I think I
have that one
I mean he didn't like all the time now
game at 5 a current I need a dance record
most of all
sorry it's allowed weapon of choice it's
like really loud
I'd like really loud I'm sorry is it allowed
to hurt your ears
I'm sorry wait I have to ask you is my
never pause history
all right that did not go into the red so
we're okay
are AIDS if he was such a great movie yeah
man I got it I got it you know what I don't
remember all of my my clips
I got so many Clips this was a great weekend
you guys remember that weekend
you yes
all right that was enough I'm back I'm back
at my back awake now
I'm back I'm back wake
no it's bash course
I whoops
is that it I got some command now now that's
it
to do to do do do do do do that's bash
python no 5000 no no no
actually download everything to is pretty
cool you need to leave right at 5 if you
wanted to spend an extra day
can I forgot all the stuff oh you're going
to make me all weepy hide
Sun always makes me weepy
that. Look at all the school kids
oh so cute and so cute it's so cute
my heart this makes me if a client or
clients
hackers
Genesee Ferris Bueller what are you doing
with your life
go do it right now
I know yeah if it is actually a little kids
are in their forties yeah
I meet you at you don't have to be a child
of the eighties in appreciate Ferris Bueller
oh my God
it's like half this is now he stressed you
were mad you can't say that first or it's
impervious to your attacks
any event there with you yeah I've been
there but I haven't been there
yeah, I'll wait as in Chicago I'm sorry I'm
mixing it with the the one in New York why
am I doing that cuz I'm an idiot I don't
know why I did that
absolute Boomer stuff
every true if I wasn't it if I was a boomer
that's the absolute jenix stuff
yeah it's like John Landis that's why John
Landis and the world of the world of the
world
Bob zemeckis John Landis and
music horse I think I'm perfectly
what are you doing I know so
I want to make a volume that's all I want to
do how is that hard
did I pick the questions did I sufficiently
killed vagrants
look at how pretty it is there's no active
ignorance on your computer thank you very
much that
I think everything
check device to see if they're still there
virtualbox
I need to learn commands for virtualbox
which I do not know
paying $54 actually pulled in my head as
before he's a boomer yes and if it by that
definition yeah leave it leave it to the
generation that invented the term Boomer to
confuse the shit out of everybody
most people that use the word Boomer have no
idea what an actual munar is they could not
tell you I'm just saying
I'm just saying what is the actual
definition of a boomer not not an okay
Boomer kind of thing what is an actual
definition of eminent over my edges of
exactly
after you sneeze I got my dog a god
baby boomer yay what is a baby boomer and
why are they called baby boomer how about
this year's a hard one what was the baby
boom
curious minds want to know
we won't attack a generation today but I
just it's just it's always fun to notice the
differences of the bus I just think it's
funny
the generation before the best generation I
don't know and I go to the generation after
the best generation
I think I think you mean the greatest
Generation that's actually think to you know
I don't want to get called that though
the greatest Generation maybe was a
generation who saved us from Trevino
whatever but it was also the generation that
gave his Chinese and Japanese internment
camps and eugenics
so Jenna could definitely forgot generation
that that's actually another term for it
yeah cuz they're kind of weird kind of
in-between everybody else
yeah and we were quiet Genex wasn't loud
remember we were loud but we were allowed in
our own alternative ways or thing until
I don't know do you want to count if you
want to count yeah you got it you got to
count you got to count
lowest fare and all that stuff in there
right
being like this if you're dabbing still a
rumor s 2016
okay yeah sorry I've had no Gen X president
I don't think we ever will gen Z gang
generation
come on now, is she is generous and she
yeah
yeah just thinking about things I read it
anyway they current
vagrant up
and all the sudden I have to pull everything
down from fresh this time
I mean okay so really that the sole reason
for doing this. I just want an FS on there
and I'm almost 100% sure
I can use in a fast just on the control
plane disc volume which is dangerous I don't
want to do that because I don't want
somebody to see that I did that even in my
sample cuz it's a bad idea
miss you feel your route is kind of control
play me like what the fuck was this guy
thinking and if if you do it if you do it to
test an FS the problem is as well as I can't
test filling it because if I fill it then
he'll blow up a control plane before it
blows up anything related NFS so this is why
I need volume I need a VM with a separate
volume that I can mount as an FS
if I have to do those steps outside of it so
be it but I can't add another volume
to you know I have to figure out how to add
volume to add an extra disc to my to my VM
yeah yeah
so so yeah
I feel like well first of all I'm kind of
glad I switched over to Mercer Bucks because
the method for providing an additional
volume is going to be very very very current
provider specific because every provider
does volumes in in control interfaces
differently and I would rather have
knowledge of her toolbox then the birds
today on that front so so yeah we're going
to need to
to do this
and I'm going to go I'm going to dive into
my research here the best way to
add external volume to vagrant
to the customized here create HD phone and
file that is size blah blah blah
what does create HD
Georgia tax SATA drive controller Ford
yeah I think it is oh God Vash is crazy
amazing
I use it all the time everyday all the time
Mash dry cleaner versus my editors
if you don't understand the Unix philosophy
then we can't really have a conversation
SMS Susan Elsa part 5
oh my God that's so amazing are you fucking
kidding me that's going to that's going to
Aunt the game up
hahaha that's going to change the game
okay that's how I cry so hard drives exist
mesh main page
or watch the book if you want to understand
what I mean about bash I'm going to say it
again it's a lot of stuff to watch but go
find the go find the day that talks about
the Unix philosophy that's my answer
actually talk at all about that
I think of that because of something that
nobody talks about it's the most important
part of eunuchs and freaking unit filters
that nobody even knows about it
oh that's phenomenal that's phenomenal.
That's going to be lit a fire under redhead
I love that they're doing that if we get
some competition to that group out there you
know I made it even wait wait.
Yeah not the same thing
your link to that tell me why
thank you for that I probably is probably my
news I didn't look for it
that's super cool I want them to have
competition
what the hell a shit
hey hi there cake Kitty
anime
that's that is going to be that is so cool
you go Susan I always like Susie
they have for years did they wow
red hat is the master not the company the
distro
oh wow that's super cool
all right
so fragile. None of those things are
available make a file to a location
Pagan roots of box Drive
Costa Rica cigarettes will know if your
folder Windows 10 do
that's crazy that let you do that I don't
have never drive
I guess I can no I don't want to map network
drive
I don't want it I guess I could do a selfie
the whole point of this is I want to be able
to bring up a drive to go with it I want to
bring up in NFS drive like from scratch
remind this woman FS Furious and snow Milda
Milda in a container
add
additional hard disk volume in vagrants
Tricia locks made it out of second hard
drive
I just I was working on some big Love Stuff
I need a list of things find out that I can
file
2nd Drive it looks good
A fuc
okay just very severe stubbed her thing
here we go it's so we make a disc drive disc
s s w d i
I didn't figure you can figure this stuff I
know I just got to Target so they're going
to use the ice cuz I think somebody already
sent me this one. Let's go through it again
so I can take him to find his license as
soon as he started being box block hostname
got it in her private got that if you have a
sub box provider
I was about to do unless the file exists
disc create HD I don't have create a 2-D
where do you get create HD
where it's going to be a VM thing
or is it provided by vagrants
you know it says customize I like that
that's an internal thing I hope that's true
cuz my storage attached
yeah I'm going to when I try to add this
it is a nice cuz you playing now
all right so the Grinch
this this this stuff doesn't work right here
by the way I don't know why it's not doing
what it's supposed to but that's that's
exactly what it says to do in is not working
give me that there's nothing this
this is
it's it's doing the VM stuff inside of here
oh my God I think I just realized something
I think I just realized something
oh my God
vagrant I am I am loving Gregor and lately I
am
I am I'm not going to lie it does what I
need I would like to terraform too but this
is doing it what I need
so sisters review
is a review Sebastian here too but it's
supposed to be
I want to do is I want to take this entire
thing right here oh I'm going to do it an
experiment
I'm doing experiments through
and this one I'm going to make have much
less memory
I don't remember having more memory 224
I think it's going to contain it I know you
can provision with ansible that was worth of
oxxo can you
god dammit yeah I know I know
I didn't purpose this a temporary don't just
don't stress
an ansible doesn't sound like it's get
bigger and all together
right I would rather look I have no problem
with that I want to come by my insulin
figured I would just rather not have a
dependency on ansible for these tiny things
if I could just put them all into a drink
cuz then I can put in the cloud and I can
say they make a cloud run whatever and then
people could just do a presentation and it
wasn't for some this all ansible
now if I could do the ansible option where
you pull down a provider and Provisions a VM
using virtual box and then does the other
stuff just by running commands
that's probably doable to write because you
can run anything right so I can run that all
the virtualbox stuff direct from the command
line that's another possibility is to do is
to make this make I'm sure there's some
ansible out there that fires up virtualbox
stuff
you know
I'm sure it's out there I just I don't know
I went I would much rather put all this
effort into virtualbox instead of making fun
yeah
I don't if I can if you look I just want to
be at work right now you know but I have a
feeling I have a feeling the answer would be
more flexible because I would be able to do
provisioning and stuff from the command line
it's basically a closer extension to bash
scripting Anthem was way better in Python in
Bosch combination some like that then then
having to force everything under Ruby and
so who knows I might end up ended up
switching over to answer before that kind of
think the vagrant Target usability and user
is a developer he's trying to provision
something really quickly just for the sake
of development and that's the that's the
sweet spot where I'm at but ansible also
could possibly do that tarform has to have a
cloud
therefore must have a cloud that's the
that's a got you there and that means you
got to essentially set up a cloud in your
house if you want to do that or on your
machine and that's hard
search her phone doesn't work or try that we
tried to cross the streams on that was
really stupid me I was a stupid we learned a
lot from it but there is a cloud
vagrant is designed to do what we're doing
we're like right in The Sweet Spot of it but
it's kind of blocking on simple things like
creating it if you're going to claim to be a
virtual machine provisional that and you
can't create volumes independently then I'm
kind of frustrated by you but I'm not giving
up hope I'm still going to shut right now I
want to test something a little bit
different though
so at the moment I'm going to cancel the
rabbit hole but
and Emmett shouldn't what I just do
oh I know what it is
I think
what would I still at the very basic thing
that I don't know how to do with a Korean I
don't know how to provision a different
separate VM with different stats in the same
vigour and file that's like a really basic
thing and I just escapes me I can't figure
it out so that's what I'm
I keep every time I see another possibility
that I'd give it a shot
UPS
if this works we'll bring up two separate
systems with different stats
this the first time that that last example
we just saw that was the first example I've
seen where they nested
the provider stanza block thing
they put the provider underneath the VM
definition that's the first time I've seen
that
that would apply to me that it can be
changed when we had it outside of that
the last one one we tested the earlier today
whatever the last one was if you had you
known liver and then cpu1 whatever
the last the last block would always win
because it was in a greater a higher scope
so what I'm testing right now is to see if
you put that inside of the internal thing
was that
if I found a word to Define you as a person
down agar down adger
with a person down as your am I just am I am
I a downer am I a Debbie Downer I kind of am
sometimes
I am I don't know what that means don't you
look it up
and informal and older person behaves like
an anchor person
it doesn't name hello fellow kids
yeah I mean
I don't try to understand who I am I just
anyway I don't see why you have to
categorize it but yeah
I'm not dead that's what I am I'm not
fucking dead
it's like you can't pull that off you can
pull the tables
that is largely true play current status
statues two things are up
see if they differ shall we figuring a
sensation control
and free I'm free
Free Fallin
wait what it doesn't make any sense
1.3 GB available
oh total are we go nevermind okay I got it
now that's Mega and not gig by 21
have fun area code
that's what we're doing ping dad
as there's a box in Vidor there is someone
else can use a broad and not just the devil
local I agree about terraforming is a reason
I went down
and you know what I'm glad you said that
because
did terraform stuff that I've been doing was
based on liver and liver just fucking died
so terraform has to have a provider just
like anything else right
if their form has a good liver has a good
every box provider then we could do all the
stuff that are for him and then our
knowledge would cross over to using care
from the wild I mean vagrant okay so let's
let's talk about the three tools that were
evaluating here really vagrants
ansible and terraform and there's a big
comparison of the three out there but I was
going to recap it really quick so
vagrant is an old tool written Ruby and
everything that targets
bringing up virtual machines really quickly
for the sake of development and testing
that's his primary goal and it has a bunch
of you know old history has got a registry
of tons of tons of stuff for that purpose
specifically for that ansible is designed as
the Univest agentless configuration manager
so you can you know use composition from
software world and things like that to
manage lots and lots of of virtual machines
as if they were real machines as if they
were software so you can like say I want you
to have this on there and you can manage
everything remotely in and do all things to
configure those things as simple as for
configurations to configurator right enter
form was specifically designed originally to
to form you know huge architectural things
composed of virtual machines and all the
other stuff that you may want to
so it's like a a larger solution to 22 it
and all three of those things that I just
mention can be used to do what we want to do
two different levels with different levels
of difficulty so when I went into this the
first thing I attempted was terraformed
actually know the first thing I checked it
was vagrant
local Devon darker just have already did
that we did that for a full month it's not
possible
yeah if you're doing okay so if you're doing
local development
yeah many Cuban kind do not okay so this is
why I ran into the dipping didn't even asked
for this before so I'll say it again so the
reason that I'm looking at virtual machines
at all instead of saying any container at
staying in a container ice World easy mini
Cube kind in my own variations on it is
because I want to write it specifically I
was going to write something that monitors
the volume utilization either as a staple
said or Damon said and that would run it
with the you essentially the underlying the
underlying disc and it won't be able to
report how close to being full it was it was
a tool hack been in the front during the
process I realized that
if I wanted to test such a thing by breaking
it so my obsession with containers you know
this last year for his application is almost
my head is I think it's Justified but
there's a borders if there's a boundary at
which you can't do stuff and the battery is
anything that's going to blow up your
so-called nodes and systems because when you
blow up a note or system that's associated
with darker in any way you blow up the host
which means I stop streaming in my whole
system goes down because I actually that was
what triggered this I was going to go try to
see how they hate what happens if I overfill
this this PVC right if I was if I totally
fill it up Beyond its capacity well the PVC
is implemented as the default Rancher
storage class which uses the darker you know
localhost to storage and that's my hard
drive
if I if I were to do that because their PVC
does not own PVC does it say can I have this
much stuff it doesn't say you only get has a
huge huge Revelation to me about storage in
kubernetes a PVC is a request for at least
this much storage
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean you can't
use more than that
there's nothing that checks to see if you're
using more it's not like carving out a
volume that's what I thought it was when I
went in to Cooper Nettie's I thought so it's
a BBC I was going to carve out a volume for
just this application know. It's a request
is a polite request to say I need at least
hey I need at least this much storage can
you give it to me please this is done and it
didn't like sleeping around but I don't
think it's I don't think it's the right way
to do it
what you are doing now. I was just wondering
about it. Dr. Guess I'm kind of trying to
explore all the different ways to do
applications development and Architectural
testing and that includes a returning to an
interest in vm's I was kind of Aunt Ivy in
there for a while wanting everything on
communities in that was dumb because you
need VM to test stuff out of my how you
going to test the device drivers how you
going to fuzz 40 days how you going to vm's
are an essential part of the development at
every level in industry and you know and
thinking that you're not going to need him
it is a 30% hit if you if you deploy a VM or
a group of yams a lot of yams and then you
put Grey's on top of that you're wasting
your wasting architectural processes that
stupid you should probably seek a nodes that
are on hardware and you said that with them
if you want to save up to 30% and
performance but if you're doing development
and you're doing you know testing and you're
trying to get the cloud doesn't do it so
it's a lot more work to do that and you
probably want to do that in the Enterprise
eventually get the performance boat boost
but you have to have things like that put in
place and you have to reboot in at the
tweaker nefud all the stuff and I've been
doing with the provision that I've been just
like shutting it down and restarting it you
see how fast it goes it's a pretty slow
right now but if I had to do that with
physical hardware and a net boot it would be
even worse right and have a great week I had
a good week my image at the save my tftp
image and I have to reboot the machine with
tape freezy gabs amount of time to get the
iterations that I need so when people say
infrastructure as code that goes for
development so when so when you're dealing
with different operation in operational
deployments architectures you can actually
tweaked a little thing for the prince
statement here redeploy your architecture
put a statement here read a player
architecture and you can either ate at same
way of software
for what and it feels really good because
it's very goddamn it and the time it would
take to do this kind of thing before was
insane and I was just insane right so this
this just has that much how much the other
one has so let's go
SSH
call the local I just different it is but
there's a problem you can't test storage
classes you can't test see a nice you can't
you can't test
different implementations of of Ingress it
can't test load balancers unless you have
your own on Prime option there's a ton of
stuff you cannot do
because you just can't because the cloud
provides its own the sewn all of its own you
know storage classes everything that you
have to like build your own and you can't
write your own software that fulfills a
storage cost for example if you use if use
if use any of the cloud providers you
another reason I'm interested because I'm
very interested in developing software for
Cooper Nettie's I wanted to know if I
eventually want to be able to code
implementations of storage class software
and stuff like that and make sores classes
that back right that the interface that's
not in the face the pain and then go
straight to Synology or whatever you I would
really like to be able to write that code
and it to be able to test a storage class
implementation there's no way you can do
that in the car because the cloud forces you
to use their stores class
he's a storage, other than grass controller
I don't think you can know there's from what
I've been told anyway I've identified a lot
but I've been told that there's some of that
stuff you can't get to you do you don't have
a choice you have to use theirs I'm almost
positive that's the case for load balancing
yours in traffic on azure
that yeah that's different though right and
I don't think that using a load balancing
you mean we have to look at each individual
thing but I know of at least two things that
do not come with
kubernetes if you're doing on priem NeoCube
ATM set
yes I'm saying so that's why that's why
that's why I would look that's why I would
look that's why that's why I want to do an
on-premise or something and and make it easy
to just fire one up and blow it away right
let me just to hold this hold Cloud cost to
which is not much just told me how we just
passed the styrofoam stuff and he did it for
like five bucks for the cloud time you know
on Amazon whatever
it is just things but you can your eye color
going outside the lines if a plant is in COD
if you do that ya don't know that for sure.
We also talked about to vomit yeah yeah it
depends what kind of like what I was doing
all the Jupiter home development and
adjustments I was using me to giving kind
for all that completely and and that's a
different thing again the reason I'm doing
this is because I am realizing there's
multiple tools in the toolbox for emulating
communities at different levels oh my God
and
it's so you know that's that's what I'm
talkin about I there's multiple tools in the
toolbox and I have sought to understand them
all so far and a couple of them I have not
yet fully fully examined and that's one of
his suit I we just I now realize I've just I
found the I finally learned something
it's easy to do development on the cob
absolutely if I was if I was going to do
development I would I would stick with the
cloud of any caves or something like that I
wouldn't but I'm not I'm about I'm about 60%
development 40% of operations I would say I
kind of want to change that ratio I want to
be at least fifty fifty and I feel like my
operation skills have gotten really soft
especially lately I can do my my mounting
and volume stuff and not having an affair
skills
yeah yeah that money for development for the
moment I would not do anything that I'm
doing right now but especially we're going
to see this actually we're going to the
calendar and I'm glad about that because
we're going to when we start doing the Boost
here let's get this give me the first boost
is going to be you know mr. Rob he doesn't
know how to do this stuff just figuring it
out with you that's the Boost that boosts
will get better every year but this boost is
designed to do nothing more than to
kubernetes eyes you know convert your
application development application for
communities in there is some strict design
differences between designing something to
run in kubernetes and just designing it to
run on a service somewhere it's totally
there's some real strong considerations that
actually impact the the back end and the
front and architecture of how to do that and
if it if you go into it thinking oh hey will
just throw it all in committees later you'll
end up designing stuff and if possible
I know you're not talking about the Boost
I'm just pulling this up because I'm just
mentioning it everybody we're going to be
talking about these issues coming up and
we're going to be doing administrative stuff
too and that's going to include why you
might want bigger and return form that kind
of thing
Senior Communities customers eksu always aw
yeah Tech stuff that is in a scent on me to
make it with her yeah it doesn't I'm taking
on the harder point on purpose because that
hardness is essential to understanding on
priem the Plymouth for Enterprise and that
is my job my job is to keep an eye on priem
non-cloud on friend Cloud deployment you
know with no other vendor running and
getting as close to a deployment at home
that I can to that same to find me that I
support at work is really critical
and it's different it's different it's
absolutely different than what you would use
in the cloud 100% And and that's that's why
I'm doing a real big plus here I don't know
if you noticed but this one has has as 10:20
and that's got one gig and and Anna says far
less wait to see her
memory I take control has
fresh air
as far as far less available total so this
one has like one less than
someone Megan this has one place that's
little bit that's about to most of the can
call another.
So if they're not know I don't know where
you're getting that impression that is not
true
not the people that I talk to everybody in
my realm is absolutely not talking about the
glass they're docking about on friend yeah
it just depends on where you're talking on
YouTube videos in an overall in oh no ways
on the internet yeah it's and marketing it's
all about Cloud it's all about picking one
of the providers and going from there if you
if you talk to investment Banks like Porsche
I don't know for sure is that the investment
banker whatever I think for sure it is as
mentioned that they are with one of these
Enterprises
yeah yeah if you're it if you're if you are
some of these other people in our community
they deal with Cloud but but their primary
purpose if I think the portion mentioned
that they were air-gapped which means they
can't even touch the cloud there is a lot of
really substantial Enterprises where there's
big money to be made and lots of work to be
done where they do not want access to the
internet for anyting and these companies are
in need of Specialists to help set up on
Prem kubernetes appointments and that is my
chosen Focus I would rather focus on that
and that's the world I kind of want to see
us living I don't particularly like your
baby different than us
I might be I mean and someone in some
respects I I mean a lot of these
multinationals that we work for I know mine
does is in Europe for sure and so
yeah yeah I would be the one to ask you
about that they have got a lot of access to
multiple Enterprises it but I think it's I
guess the caution I would say is it there
there is a lot of things happening that no
one hears about
if you go to a conference and you hear about
it we talked about that with you macaroni on
the sap Sunday when we when we had him all
over the interview
remember that web is much more skewed toward
Cloud yeah and my research absolutely when
when that's occasions is a hundred percent
skewed towards called because if they can
get out there really fast and and that makes
it that's fine that's like a nice
alternative to serverless for them right and
I'm I support that completely in fact that's
what they say about hybrid cloud like our
organization does have stuff on the cloud
and it's usually the public facing
microservices and rest apis and things like
that that are in the cloud and then they
just did the fat communicating between them
is a thing you know
going to find a job
I mean there's lots of ways to get into a
group home lots of ways to get into it I am
made the booster so we can with my opinions
on how to get started in the best way
recently wrote A Blog about that
yeah this is a recent thing I just wrote
actually
I am not trying to put you off at your store
advertised I'm just I've already answered
this question is a lot so you don't have to
agree with the stuff that's in there I just
that's how I answer
I'm sitting outside of a structurally
communities
so we actually have made a discovery I have
made a discovery I don't give a damn about
anyone I want them in with my statements
there so I won't do that
what have just discovered is the proper way
to ensure that
you get a different number and the truth of
the matter is I actually know when I can do
now
and I'm going to change it to something that
actually matters
and I want to know what that means so in my
in the setup I want to have an if statement
that says if the name is cloud I want to see
fuse Eliza I mean I want
I want to see videos of I just want one so
I'm going to say this if name equals and I
don't know how to do this
control Right End else
and I want to see fuse
it was one that I have been looking for how
to do that and the secret is by embedding
the same provider inside of the iteration
which makes me very happy so that should
actually work I'm going to try that now
vagrant destroy
vagrants
I love your work and working within a camera
so see Alexander so you can play and I can
read
yeah that depending on the application
that's going to be fine but I would I would
maintain that that's going to be less and
less possible and that application
developers creating significant software are
going to have to stop thinking about
I'm just going to make this thing I'm going
to head over to devops going to put it into
a container and put in a couple days I have
to think about it
the more significant the application let me
give an example of Alaska search right the
more significant the application the more
aware of how it's going to be deployed it it
has to be more aware of those considerations
the developers have to be and and this
simpler the application is just a micro
servers and one gives a shit it's answering
one question while the storage involved and
so I'm going to that would be that would be
my suggestion is that people doing software
development and need to start thinking about
what is this going to look like when it's
fully deployed and if you just want to be a
programmer keep your nose down and do you
know it's clean and just just you know give
me this thing I'll give you the same for
this out pointers this one service has to
answer this question but if you're going to
move into the software architecture and
design which is what most of her when she
knows I think want to do then you you have
to think about the larger picture about it's
going to be deployed and
can't do that without understanding and
communities and doctor from another larger
perspective for example we had somebody know
this is not I'm not putting anybody down
here but we had somebody the other day try
to compare go to Python and by how big the
containers were and they were putting go
they're putting a go compelled binary into
an Alpine container and comparing that to
python and a python VM inside of a python
container and that is a newbie mistake
that's a newbie mistakes because they don't
understand containers and I didn't
understand containers a year ago but one of
the advantages of go is that you can do a
friend's couch container and they just met
today like thank you so much for saying that
because I didn't run trash container and I
went from 2.6 you know whenever MB to 1.5
for The French Press container that's
because the developer didn't understand the
advantages of doing a front sketch container
and they may if they were making a software
decision about what language to pick and
stuff like that at the design session while
they are we going to develop this blah blah
blah
they may have picked node or typescript or
Ruby or Southern Python and it be fine but
they would have made a significant
performance decrease because of that
decision when they could have wrote it
written it and go or roster anything is
compiled the data from scratch container
that means that the developer has to know
what from Chris trash containers work with
and how darker works because that's how it's
going to be able to lead to Floyd and that
it depending on this the number of of you
know the pods are going to end up from that
piece that component that's a really
substantial change really substantial on the
order of like two or three hundred percent
safe means of of ramen and all the other
discs everything so that's why that's why I
mean that's that's why I think the higher up
you want to be in the software development
architecture their money you want to make
the more higher you you're going to need to
understand
you know the cloud the cloud thing the cloud
native thing and it means thinking of your
app from the very first day about how it's
going to be deployed
yeah
Play Summer came into communities and they
had no idea what persistant voice for it's
going to happen I'm just saying what but
other people are aware of I'm just saying
that
I'm just saying that it's not going to be
enough to just learn typescript and write
code that's not going to be enough going
forward more and more
as a volunteer form I think most of us
absolutely absolutely are and that's why I
want I wanted to kind of shoe horn my my
local stuff in Dancing with their form just
because I didn't want to the cognitive
overhead of maintaining Ruby very very vague
and file knowledge and I would rather learn
as volunteer form than vagrants right
but that's not the sweet spot so it's kind
of kind of hard to do that big rinse up
it's going to bring up all three not if I
did this right then only the control plane
should have two CPUs and everything else
should have won
and I'm going to confirm this is true I'm
going to make us a lot about this cuz I've
learned something here I keep hearing about
polygamy
yeah does that does that help your buddy
still a fucking hate HCL I wanted to like it
so bad cuz I'm such a hash of core Fanboy
but I cannot like it
I just can't I try so hard and I just cannot
like it yeah
I might I might be with you on that I
continue to hear really respected people in
my my community recommend for me to Mia and
I I definitely want to look at that
Yogi really hear you can holyshit
does it run on top of terraform or is it a
separate product from terraform that's super
cool
that is really really cool
sometimes the easiest and simplest yes I
agree is a mushroom is it better is it
compatible
I can find get something videos on YouTube
channel I have to find a specific one
based on those ideas you got filter
you can't just do videos on that maybe if
you want to search my soul casting go to get
Hub and search
let me show you so I can which one are you
looking for group hug what are you looking
for communities for example right
set query vagrant
that'll give you another that's a link that
will give you and you can search GitHub for
specific things if you want to search for
videos you have to go it's so hard to find
the video search yeah if you're going to
search for vagrant I don't think I have
anything on vagran I have beds on links
the search bar on YouTube is almost
impossible to find ya let me show you the so
I made a little thing to help people out but
if you go to YouTube and you want it you can
probably know this more than I do but if you
go to somebody's channel right
hi Rob. So then you click over here do you
have to see what I just did there
in order to search just my videos you have
to go all the way to the end and you click
this little thing here
and then you can search for whatever you
looking for you can search for
where do you find a filter based on ID
number another number is not in there
there's some that it not everything has a
video I should probably say so but the
things that happen if it's in the
description and I also haven't made
everything into a video so yeah and there's
there's two this is the best I can do
I just get lab my knees are really all these
are like years old
get a real job not just a job yeah that
doesn't haveyeah that doesn't have a video
that's not a video yet
no that's
is that chat did I did I did I do it wrong
Zedge
chat job they're so that's the if you linked
to that
that will give you the right one
yeah I would like to make it easier to
search but so far it's
I'm always trying to figure out better ways
of doing this is more of the most important
thing of all is that I can find my own stuff
I won't lie I'm very selfish that way
YouTube Channel video search doesn't work
the greatest if it's tagged with an ID
I was like a number
well I'm trying really hard to make it so
that you guys can find searchable content
why is it taking so long
this is something I've noticed it takes
significantly longer to start to do all of
this stuff with virtualbox
Gmod the human liver and stuff was way
faster to provision like like twice as fast
cell yeah I'm doing right now is I'm
yeah
so you know why are we doing this again well
we're doing it because there's more support
for virtualbox and apparently it's easier to
create volumes which I wanted Mountain
that's what got me switching back over so
this is nice so vagrant
status give me all of the statuses on the
system and that's like way too long
alright so let's see vagrants
SSH control
l s u p I wonder if I'll even work
she name is that sound can you actually
execute a control command
I wonder if you can execute control
coronavirus Circle you can nice oh God I'm
learning so much
that she Alice see if you
so keep your family God dammit
that looks like there's only one see if you
on the control plane
that means my if statement failed
that means my instatement failed
yeah there's something wrong here I don't
know what it is
I don't know I don't know if Ruby I mean
it's been so long I don't remember it
all right so let's do
b l a c
no no no no no no no Ruby Rose Ruby
complete guide
let's see here definition and whatever
I want to know if the string
AccuWeather
I mean it should just be equals right
and I feel so dumb I feel like that is
famous not working
I really have to do like string match or
some shit
no I had it right I didn't write you so why
I want to set only works with memory
god dammit
maybe I need to have this earlier
when you think you might have any ideas
maybe maybe there's not
I don't know I feel like it's not getting
here
I mean this is a long way to do this but
you know I can probably do it here
I'm giving you this get rid of this give me
this give me that give me that
and keep this
parents LOL
well is it run this like every time
let's give you a Jersey
only gotwhen we got
see here
I wish it was say it it's not saying I'm
going to have to go all the way in here and
see what happens
why does it have to pull the whole thing
every time I think we need to do that link
thing so that it doesn't do it as fast I
mean it didn't take as long
I don't know man
all right that wasn't as bad
why did it have to run all that control
stuff everytime I don't understand why I had
to do that
every student read it again I said something
about CPUs and there that you can't change
it's it's like freaking me out so
apparently could change memory but we
couldn't change the number c fuse
so I can buy if I change the number of
I mean let's do the other one let's do node
Austin don't wanna
so same thing same thing
more more stuff to tester
let's change put memory in here
I mean
I could have swore that we just figured out
how to do this and how we have a provision
differ memory based on the the the name that
we did that
we did it by providing by providing another
VM
I wonder I wonder if it's because we have is
like this template very well here I wonder
if the
remind me Casino name is to find here
I know I don't know I don't even know how to
test it I don't know I just feel like
I'm we okay so we we broke all of this out
and we did two separate ones and that worked
so now the thing I'm trying to do is trying
to say okay if the string matches this do
something conditional inside of here
and that's not happening so
I could be there's two CPUs or not something
we can change or could be the air
conditioner is not getting matched
but then it was multiple times with it if
condition was matched so
it has to have something to do with house
being cold
because it's Puget Sound spewed all that
stuff across the screen
so so that has something to do with it
I mean I've actually I think I know how to
do this without usingand without using this
statement so let's stick with that
and put in here do you know who wanted to
and we have those 10 gig of memory provision
and 1st ncph
yep all right so let's keep that head up
here would just get rid of this
I want to keep this for multiple control
points I'm going to have one for now
I might add like 3 or 4 control place like I
wanted to control one or something right
so really that Emily B is to
since these are virtually the same things
which is why I was figuring I can call if
I'll call another function most I just want
to see if you think that would work out so
let's try to do this this actually worked
with memory so it could be the fact that it
could be his memory just into it
that could be that could be the option
Suns schedule
I'm going to save the shelter cuz those take
forever to run
and come back if this works I know this is
like slow morning but I kind of need to do
it
hahaha do do do do do do
they are insecure key detected we will
replace it automatically
it does make me wonder if we could do this
is just with ansible I'd much rather do this
with ansible and vagrant
it's just yet another cold one right
assholes got way bigger future than bigger
until for this kind of thing
it is said to have a VM hell you can write a
script
automatically
I don't know why I say that that way I'm
just I just do
I have my own weirdness
one CPU let's see about control and be mad
if it's not there
God dammit what the fuck
that's only three of megahertz that's
interesting
this is what I wasthis is what I was afraid
of so this is the same behavior I was seeing
before that makes me wonder
I know it makes you is it 2.9
you see what I'm saying this this provider
line right here overrides the CPUs for this
memory doesn't memory doesn't watch if I
give this
I already tested this this is one of my
testing you know it's not working so I don't
know what the fuck is going on so this one
we tested and it definitely works
so yeah I don't know
I kind of want to look there I am like this
close to just doing this with a bash script
and then putting that in ansible
I am really close to doing that because
because the thing that's fucking is up is
the Ruby from the vagrant that's like not
being interpreted properly if I was if I
knew if I was dealing with the command for
the provider that's creating the allocation
I think I would be better I would probably
be better to do this has been stripped
I'm like I'm really seriously thinking of
doing it that way because half of this
project is in the provision script most of
the project is in the provision script right
and all that does is just get run on the
system which I can definitely run just by
putting it over there on my own
and I have to provision Avea volume and I
have to figure out what the fuck did the
main lot late languages to provision the
volume and every one of the add-ons that
says to do volume permission he says to exit
out of your Ruby vagrant and run this
command that was going to provision this
volume for you willing to just fucking
provision the volume using VA using the
verse about commands directly and call it a
day
I think that the extra layers of technology
in here are fucking is up on the fact that
it can do that he can provision you know
three of them at the same time it's not even
doing any synchronously the fact that it's
pulling the image down off the internet and
cash it into doing all that that's kind of
cool but I really don't give a shit
it is
I mean it is spitting it out you know but
those are all things that can be done from
command line calls to to virtualbox and
virtualbox is the primary provider anyway
for vagrant
call Vivian box manage APA ya using the
customer saying yeah because you saw all
that they are every time that they had a
vagrant thing yeah be customized modified
bmidc fuse to ya
right
but the thing that's taking the thing is
kicking my ass right now is it it's this
nebulous Ruby object that it is sort of
Adventurer than is called a different
intervals obviously the look every time I
change of every time I change the value here
the last value wins so this has no is no
sense of scope or anything and if you're
going to call it infrastructure as code then
you give you should probably do things like
you know observe the scope of the Blocker in
which which I'd I swear to God I got to work
with memory we just tested that it worked I
was really hopeful then I went to do it with
CPUs it didn't work so I'm going to test the
PM's now and see if it works
otherwise otherwise there's some arbitrary
order in which these two things are executed
and whichever one set the CPU last wins and
this stuff is escaping out of this block
scope and it's affecting all of it as if it
were a global that's like all the problems
you have a global programming and is it just
makes me want to throw the whole fucking
thing at the door again because I'm fighting
with Ruby here I'm not even fighting with
vagrant I'm fighting with Ruby here and if
I'm going to be fighting with Ruby you might
as well fight with ansible and Bash which I
know which are more relevant for the My
overall job than vagrant
and I ain't got no style of vagrant I like
that it's been able to pull up everything
pretty quickly and it does it does some
extra magic that I would have to figure out
how to do is Bash
it almost did something it look I'm not it's
not on the shit list but it's okay
right now until until I figure one thing out
if they got his kind of back on the shit
list
because it's a
a really really hard thing to say I want one
disc with this much memory as an extra
volume
that should not be difficult the whole point
of a thing like this is to be able to say
hey give me this extra discs I have this
final and amount it right and
Municipal point of provision in the first
place
the fact that this you see me change these
things 3 or 4 times right watch what happens
if I change it if I change
how many something else to test this I'm
going to change this one to two and you
watch all of them are going to have two CPUs
even though they are completely scope
differently all right and if someone's going
to say dumbass why you doing that this is
why I didn't tell me that I want you to tell
me that but the fact that changing the CPU
count here is going to affect this EP
account of the controller of the control the
end that's up here which is entirely
different block
it's fucked up family work Sia
yeah we'll see you at 5 if I make it through
it
so so this is this is really this is really
I didn't even construction trade this this
last test is the first is the last time I'm
going to fuck around with anger and believe
me I have been a vagrant fan has been doing
things really well up to now but this shit
with volumes and the ship was scoped
configuration sets is a pain in the ass I
would much rather have a yamel file for that
and if I have to make my own tools to do
that so bad and I just might it's just might
because it's not that hard I mean it's not
that hard it's supposed to be just calling
calling provider is right well who really
gives a shit about any provider besides will
Starbucks right now and then I can guess you
wanted understand delivered stuff I guess
people wanted to that bed but why I had a
layer of abstraction there when I just go
direct to the thing that you're using and
interpret that
so I'm going to if this doesn't work I'm
going to try with ansible next to do
did you try to do see if you can sit in
change change note to do
she was one I think I think I think what
you're saying is any the answer is yes
think I tried that
the test that I did that appeared to have
taken was I did this appear and this down
here and I ended up with machines that had
different memory so far the seat fuse is not
working though
now when I say V. Two CPUs it does say to
but then I wonder will this one I'm doing
LLC for you is that the mistake is Ellis if
you showed me one CPU with 2 GHz
and I know I have four GHz CPUs
so what I wonder is going to do something
magical with a number of CPUs and then just
throw it down the makers I don't I don't
know how that stuff works so that was one of
the reasons I was maybe talking about that
and Prok I didn't look it in for Oculus look
at that next time it's possible it's very
possible that I'm looking at the CPUs
completely incorrectly
that could be the case I would really like
that to be the case actually so
let's first of all try free Dash age
ellipse now we're just trying to memory
comparisons right
total is you know
let's try on control
I want
oh no I'm really confused because it's like
it's not even seeing the two different
things anymore
Speck provider for the machine at the global
config I think you're right
well you know okay I honestly I don't
remember the test I did I need to recreate
an eye test
so the test I'm pretty sure that test I did
was I I did two completely separate configs
yeah I think that's what happened I thought
I was going to be able to scope it within
here though and you cannot do that
so
oh wait oh my God I feel so fucking stupid I
see immediately what my problem was to see
my problem is
I found it I think I found it I found it so
I'm back to liking bigger and again
there's no problem here config I'm so stupid
I'm stupid I feel stupid I feel so stupid I
was so stupid that was definitely the
problem that would explain perfectly because
that was it was almost as if I was changing
a variable in a scope outside of the block
because I was
it's exactly what I was doing all right well
in a live and learn live and learn
I feel very confident about this next
attempt I do I feel very confident that was
it
the reason I was doing it since I was trying
to test that I have made some people have
this this van provider thing outside of the
scope and then some people have it inside of
the scope so I would be really surprised if
this doesn't work if it doesn't work I went
through a bigger nothing fucking window
I'm sure it will though cuz that was like
user error I was like oh he
we're not doing all of her Disney so it
should go pretty fast
Reagan up I really don't want to have to
maintain Ruby my whole life
so I'm still not completely
yes we have a very complex relationship so
what else is new
here's my questions
do we still want to even if this works do we
still want to look at ansible for this kind
of thing and and
do you think ansible skills are better than
vagrant skills
this is strong part of me that wants them
thinking about others as well it's like when
we helped introduce this whole thing to
others who are just getting into the
infrastructure engineering kind of thing how
essential is vagrant we do and supposed
essential we know that we know that
something like telephone or Plumbing is
probably going to be a part of it as well
you know I don't know I figured I think
Megan is more on the bike yam
people people even okay so developers are
Developer friend earlier was saying that
when they have them at as they used their
former and terraformed to do is to carve out
their children in the cloud and then they do
development there and they bring it up or
take it down and stuff and that's pretty
common right
at turbo Mansoor sense will make sure I
don't run across the lawn M so it's what I'm
trying to get my I keep coming back to
oh yeah they still do there's a lot of
people that still here but I keep coming
back to
if we can even if it's a little bit more
difficult because ansible a terraformer not
designed to do this what we're doing
everything we can wait to yeah yeah
it wouldn't use anything from you from a
vagrant is is ansible as a red hat thing so
you must not use your head
but you're probably aren't you running a red
hat Enterprise self OS I was going to say
really your whole system's I don't know
about that
I am having hit a few barriers there already
I don't know how do you do you put us in
Lenox back on it then cuz it doesn't come
with it right
interesting
wait now I'm really confused
are we wanted the same we wanted the same
memory of course you did we want some lsusb
I'm sick of you wait
come on
never go that was it all right
I can't believe you have you have a pain
running said haha interesting
yeah I don't like asking Lenox at all if I
could get a ride around it I would
does that fulfill all your like government
requirements of stuff
because I mean are like let you know that
kind of thing
I feel like that was a long and drawn-out
tedious thing
a name equals control ac fuse
are securities a sec interesting
a ever played with Harbor we've been looking
for Harbor for a scanning I'm just curious
yeah I mean it seems like the best internal
registry these days right I actually did
come back to we need to set it up as soon as
I'm doing all this artifactory yeah that's
another big one
yeah
interesting options out there I know it's a
tough it's a tough to pick him right hard to
tell to help guide others and say hey which
you know which things do you need to learn
here so many options and it is a crapshoot
you know that you invest in the right thing
and I can be very frustrating isn't making
her coming into it it's like which things
should I learn you know
oh nice try
it worked last time so the only thing I
added here was an if statement because I
wanted to make sure my review I am pretty
sure my baby was correct and it just was in
the wrong scope so this should fix that
problem
I mean I have to remind myself that just the
ability to redo Baker destroy vagrant up is
a massive savings and time if you were
trying to imagine trying to provision these
systems using actual machines to do this
testing
the iterations I did in the last hour alone
would have taken me a full day
I mean I would just it just it just blows my
mind how much virtualization
how much virtualization has sped up work on
every front and Industry whether it's you
know looking 40 days like the most of those
or you know sampling network engineering in
architectures or testing up and it's just
is really amazing fact it's so easy it's
causes has caused all of our infrastructure
to get far more complicated because we can
script it and because we can script it then
all of a sudden navigations we make are not
just singular applications there now
composed of multiple components that spread
across multiple containers running on both
the movie ends and that increases the
complexity and if we don't have these other
tools we will be shipped out of luck cuz I'm
to be so complicated we would never do
anything like that in the old in the old
days back in with no one server went out
kind of situation
aunt
see her
a stranger thing that should be fine
two-course oh my God
my if statement is not working
I didn't change the preset messages to
change your number it's not working
you can't do this oh I put name equals
that is like the worst how many of you made
that mistake before you know what that is
what's wrong with interpreted languages
that's one of the main reasons not to use
and interpret language everybody want to
explain to our friends out there what just
happened
because I used assignment guess what
assignment always evaluates to true so the
condition was never fall so that else never
happened
I cannot tell you how come in that are is is
really really common infected in and no you
have to do a job description have to do
three of them to get it to really write you
measure asked me to talk about Unix Linux
kernel different distros different teas and
why they should try doctor and get something
better to tell me when I finished you get a
raise or you're fired
what are the two yes but it's talk are you
fucking kidding me
oh my God you know what it came out in 2013
I knew it was I just didn't learn it I knew
how important is going to be I still didn't
learn it I didn't need it if I didn't think
I did you know how much it would have helped
my education I could have made Docker images
for the kids to take home put on their
laptops and stuff and I didn't do that I
regret to no end that I did not learn Docker
in 2013 at the same time that I deployed
skills tag because I was sending people home
with virtual machines that stuff and if I'd
known about darker I could have seen it for
station Docker containers and I could have
said all of my python stuff as a Docker
container run on their laptops and they
would have had to log into the server
but it didn't and I force them all the log
remotely SSH into the server
on a big exercise machine like I see Iron
Man series
not a long time no
oh my God that's crazy is it going to rain
over there
all right last time then get this right
this Irish talk about something related
oh my God
oh my God I'm so sad for you I'm so sad for
you
you know I thought I was bad that everybody
on my team uses putty to connect to the
server they have no idea what two months is
or how to use it and I'm just like or even
screen for that matter
and they're great people the right people I
am not putting them down there phenomenally
brilliant people are just amazing people
they just they don't think it's necessary
I don't want to do this Tech talk anymore
all God he wants me to show how to click
here and there
did he have you talked about Lenox and then
bitching about it and become relevant
if you don't use Linux I don't know man but
I you know what are well I'm glad you can
come here and vent if there's one thing I've
always wanted to be for the people that
build a lot of communities then you know
it's the retreat for teachers and we would
all get together on the beach literally we
would get together on a literal vide virtual
Beach and we were just shoot the shitz and
just complain and vent and then we would go
back to our work and we would get stuff done
and if this community can be that for people
as well as helping them learn I think it's
really important people understand that that
your job is not everything and otherwise of
the job you're working at the people don't
know Linux don't know what team was just
doing whatever right and they might have a
limited view it's super easy to start to
believe that that's how the whole world
looks at things and that's wrong so yeah
traffic status
10 years behind in their go to that but it's
also behind what's today's market yeah yeah
it is an and that's kind of
but there's more than one God hey look to
see if he has to work now
oh my God I feel like that's a major thing
I've definitely walking to shut down all
right so
so we got we got I got the conditional note
stuff at now it back to volumes and you know
if it's I am praying to God that it's
something we can do inside a vagrant without
having to get specific but I've been taking
a quick break I'm going to walk around at 7
so and we come back we're going to do the
volume mounting
and that if if if I don't do anything else
tonight except for the volumes to melt and
use in a Fest so be it
Osoyoos tattoos
I get there from here like a dislike Wick
alright so
love to Virtual box and tighten up
yeah I'm good one thanks pal.
Yep thank everybody for coming by I'm I'm so
going to be here I'm just going to take off
boy oh boy oh boy
all right yeah I'm going to I'm going to be
and go going to break her
my brain is like mush right now
08 we're going to keep this up this is how
did you get yeah we were going to get that
one all right
all right see you in a bit
oh that's very good cheers
put a case on it this time yeah
Rona
so yeah c'est la vie
city of Eden island survival mode
all right we're going for it we're going for
an FS mounts
which means we have to get it volume created
first
which means we're back to breaking it in
wonderful ways a Porsche
tagged at Beast I kinda want to tag him with
a spending special
tagged free and if s
I'll delete that time later but I just want
to be able to go back to that take if I need
to that specific one
all right alright alright alright alright
alright vagrant
file then what else we need
what else do we need
god dammit god dammit
we need
I don't know if he's going to work this
brand is going to kill me I was going to try
and set a variable
I don't know why it has to be the second
disc we say b a n f s
if they don't want to learn who I am am I I
said the wise are you documented procedures
I know it's probably safe to say but I
understand your concern there
after all this yeah actually really am
enjoying this I'm actually liking this more
than gaming lately I had I had I won four
straight games with serious down so they
just probably last night you can look at it
to my team in history if you believe me
so I might do that later I'm actually my
stream that I should cuz I have a build now
that's like guaranteed to stump
this going to say and if ass add vdi
and then we're going to do we're going to do
Devine ISD Target is CBN box we got that is
he Target Hussein we got that
good thing we only want to do it to one of
the machines we don't want to do it to
control
I kind of feel like I need to do a control
separate from the other stuff but I don't
really need to
and I didn't reveal or python that's a tough
call a man that is a tough call I I don't
know I've been I was thinking about that in
the shower just now is like what do we need
to know
I probably would say I mean I love Ruby to
but I probably would say python because the
ansible ansible python
so
ansible hands down is my favorite
configuration tool ever seen I like way more
than terraform who is definitely easy it's
like really surprised the problem is it just
doesn't have logic I mean it does but
all right so we have
when do the NFL thing we're doing right now
is a text to tect
yeah
I mean there are so many choices but they're
fine right
I've heard people say it just looks like a
big dictionary list mcmap you know unless
file exists
I said I could roll or going to say
I said it's going to say unless
well that exist God damn Ruby is so old
no. Customize
Crazy Steve file name
disc
n f s a video
n f s
omfs
I think llamo I mean it's as much as problem
problems it's definitely
for consideration stuff
there's a ton of stuff about Ruby I really
love
I don't think this is going to work because
I don't see how it's going to run it
transfer that over multiple lines without a
problem I can write
that's a very Ruby thing to do two line I'm
up now they are giving stuff like that
should have automatically thing
what is declarative right
the key to it is it raining in Des Moines
models of ammonia
I kind of want to try this all an ansible
and see if I could just shows for bringing
up the
bring up the VM do you know
is a strong part of me that wants to do that
in the end of the Ruby behind I like to I
like to focus on I mean it's good to know
Vince is bigger in a little bit but I'd like
to focus on Ansel and terraformed above
everything else and possibly possibly follow
me because we have to do is she all right
the mostly ansible ansible is like so cool I
really really want to get into it
I don't even know if that's valid Ruby
what is it no i r l
God I don't remember
I didn't notice it pytorch has been
developed by the AI Labs at Facebook / meta
I did not know that
Swig stomp spiced
yeah I need to do
yeah everybody loves pipe or towards just
like way easier than testifying hearing
so I don't I don't know I haven't gotten
into it enough to be able to tell but can
way the fuck is all that stuff
production environments for research I think
that's that's been
what I've been hearing
Hip Hop fuck it
I'll provide assistance for winter time to
get serious yeah I've got probably probably
getting on Hay how that is it going to be a
c e wheel of busy here I just don't get an
opportunity could do anything with it
yeah
what's a provision shop at revision are safe
to keep your cards true
so what are we doing about example as if I
need a variable disc
is that filing for the second driving to
finding the new harddrive criticizing want
if I do find a controller and porch to test
you
wait we can do that part so we did see if
you a memory
interactive mode I like them when they push
each other like that you know
I think that's good for everybody
we do I have an idea I guess I do
36 ID Source ETL
say that controller
pour one divide 0
type a CD
htd medium
disc wait I screwed up what else is new
yep I mixed myself time device support SATA
controller
sorry i d create file name
variant size that's why size 20 x 24
s s 2 GB with it whenever
oh
I guess that's the only one that has an end
very interesting
Panera customized storage
unless and customized end
I thought my check is again so we have yeah
it was such a good stuff it's big stuff
let's file exists disco and Fs
that there isn't an FS
all right if there is a file there's an f s
file let's do our thing
no customize free HD
I find this isn't just have to memorize or
just no way of like not looking this up
drain fixed size 28 device
I don't need that when I need that I need
that.
So that's it so we're going to create a hard
drive file on an FS effect size 2500
and classes for Catholics
I don't know no and customized storage
attached
how do you say controller
works one device Arrow so we have to make a
controller
Rowan device stereotype HD
and then what hi bass do you medium disc
sec to read that way alright so storage
Georgia tax ID search City AL
text Rona Parts on device zero type HD
medium disc
can I take ZicamI think I found that
provision Shall Pass provision that a safety
patrol true good right
Define the control in Port to attach this
new hard drive to the 6th floor is what is
used for my Birchbox
instance running on OS X is everything on
your setup
I don't know if I need any certificate or I
think probably say two controllers fine
though
it's a very different opinion or set of I
just might have been a huge partnership
between meta and Amazon
animal bite or stuff apparently a good
percentage of Facebook friends on Amazon
so it might it might be just sit or
something else in your case it's okay
and if it's been filled out and you could
check is it and your hard drive is being
such
see you at the station
sgbc there's a SUV that's so cool
they have him something else you're so cool
about and we really really have to punch for
some shoes cuz you can actually fuck around
look like at this partitioning of stuff on a
virtual machine you cannot practice at stuff
on.
Yeah
by torch I think I agree
they look like they're having their offering
all their stuff over there that's going to
be a big deal
no matter what you think of the company's
that's going to be a big deal for machine
learning so you have it helps that makes you
someone else helped you and if you want to
add more than hard drives a bigger build see
example
I just got some ideas how I exist
wait what I just have to do part 1 and 2 and
it's a different this just name
I'll fuck that is awesome that is awesome
I think I've been open I do
oh my God that's so awesome okay so that's
all I need you please let this work
vagrants up
and find out where my messages for me an
object that's right
I call that n f s Bridget a disc
Missy disc like it's a disc one their desks
to later
and I'm going to call a d ring as a disc
disc
making up vagrant
god dammit I know curation section
customized bulshit
I called bullshit
I don't know
all right so that Define GFS Jam
I think I look so it says TV viewing from
Vidor
provider
I know I know I did you wrong I need to know
no better yet just needs to be the road
aha I sent that's what it takes
buy timer oh snap
what machine already provisioned
running a provision reusable. Vagrant
destroy
annihilate decapitate vagrant decapitate
it's the Brandy talking
wait time for you to do something that takes
less brain power like DotA
I'm happy though can I just say I am happy I
I cannot tell you I love you I'm this stuff
that we're doing right now
warms my heart I mean it cuz we're actually
I I can see a clear path to like total
kubernetes Mastery by using these techniques
even if I don't get them out this right away
I can do something else
the customization command failed
it could not attach the storage because
there wasn't any storage that's why
if I file as far as this
could even get there I'd rather not say that
as I'm guessing I'm guessing it's not say
that
error cannot find control namesake before I
was afraid of that I guessed it I guess the
problem even though I don't know the answer
I guess the problem I'm happy I'm happy I
feel like a giddy little boy
it's true it's true all right so come on you
can do it you can do it
spoiled I'm been foiled
can I find a guitar named say that what the
fuck kind of controller you want Versa box
god dammit I don't know what kind of
controller I need
I don't know storage attached with the fuck
I shall try something vbox
I just realized something all these things
all of these things right here are sub
commands yeah there's some commands of
v-bucks manage
yeah I just figured that out all by myself
vbox manage
there's no completion goddammit is there a
completion god dammit
I have never used vboxmanage in my life so
I'm going to go look at Dad's about
he likes manage lots of shitz come on please
please have a completion thing
oh my God you're so verbose medium in Folk
loansnap
manager Oracle why do they put oracal in
there at Oracle is for the bottom doesn't
mean they can call itI mean they can call it
Oracle
I'm sorry. That's exactly what it means
is B filter is that property camera floga
text raw data medium property as opposed to
medium hot and cold property oh my God
there's so much shit here there's so much
shit here to learn
1800 lines of stuff to memorize
come on is their completion here somewhere
is there there is but it's not something
that I would do
I have to know I have to know completion for
V
by the way why didn't the fuck did you make
his type uppercase you piece of shit
he likes Mexican place in scrap this this
version of the fishing was initially based
on Sebastian's have to go to her at some
point. For Scratch friendly version of
surface of any system if you have to measure
for a bra
I tell him there isn't a compilations rib
oh my God what kind of shit is this you
telling me you don't make it by default
a piece of shit because it's made for
Windows in Oracle
I give that out I gave that up I give up so
device manager
create HD Dash 8 and what do we have here
apparently we can create a disc
beautiful me which we did a white says
create medium
m s MSP disc
the device if you're ready let's do another
one let's do
attached storage oh boy
at my god dammit alright attached storage
what is that about
attached storage oh my God but maybe it's
not there
it actually is not there it says invalid
command you dumbass
I regret to inform you that storage attached
is the name right here we go
I use my mouse to me
wow look at that as far as charged, and say
what you said for an hour or so the password
tells Naruto she just got to plug in for
cement server Target 241 cuz I haven't heard
one in a long time
what are we looking for honey what are we
looking for
let's see here so if we do username
I'm having a complete brain fart I don't
know which one to do Fort storage unit d v m
name
maybe we don't need it
maybe we can just get rid of it I shop it
off hey how's it going Conrad
you didn't miss cute man two man
QVC colorqube man I call Cube man target
server
protocol weather for oh God
well what do you know I'm usually doesn't
even exist
I feel ashamed I feel very ashamed
I feel ashamed
what are we got we've got
I can't think if I was time for me to go
home oh wait I am home
stores attached storage
it doesn't have it doesn't look like you
know what are they lied
I want my money back storage attached is not
a thing and we had a storage CTL is not a
thing is not a thing
did I miss it oh there it is it's the first
thing
okay so but I don't know what type of source
ETL
pretzel time for internet search what type
of
best a storage c t l should I use
should I use for Lenox
virtualbox vagrant virtual storage
Mama bum bum boom boom boom boom boom
provision that work customized towards
attached IDE controller
that's what we want we want IDE controller
part 1 Etc
well I D controller okay okie dokie okie
dokie
okie dokie I have as much as I have good
feelings about this
I haven't because the internet said so so it
must be right I are you
here we go
vagrants up me grown up
please work please work please work please
work it past people customizations what
holyshit
oh my God they got a bigger it's like that I
really want to do it as a little because I
spent all this time doing this right
hell if this works we will be in Fat City
where did the term come from Fat City
there's no more Brandy that is a sad thing
mother's running I know exactly what to do
hi Doris Decker
I can't wait for that long
cheers to you
cheers tocheers to vagrant for making me an
NFS volume I'm so happy
this is very very very positive oh my God is
going to work
cheers for coffee
Tony you make it through it don't make it
through the day buck up camper
as they say in England keep your pecker up
night is that it's anything else we we we
had we had a president and Mission president
from Great Britain ring going to be exact
while I was in my mission in the Caribbean
islands I was on Martinique specifically
and the French island of Martinique that's
actually where I learned how to speak French
and
the president would come visit very very
infrequently it was it was pretty apparent
that he did not like the Caribbean is
probably a racist fuck I don't know anyway
on the bright side it's Friday though that's
true hell is it to Friday's tomorrow so true
story
Kia on the are missionaries on her Island
where the Press were waiting for this run so
I can tell you the story I guess I can do
this so yeah so so so so Island where would
I get very frustrated I didn't say
Australian I didn't know I did I was just
the point that I don't know where Tony's
from and
we were really depressed cuz we couldn't get
anybody to get baptized in this church that
told you you couldn't go to heaven if you
were black until 1976 I wonder why they
didn't want to join in retrospect I think
it's pretty clear anyway so he would come
there and he would give his fee's like
missionary conference is where they'd make
us nice food and bring it to the room to get
us all riled up to go out there and kind of
hurt those people you know just like in the
in the Book of Mormon musical if you ever
seen it which is phenomenal and and no I kid
you not he he got up at the pulpit and he
said
I know Ellis Summit. My Max has horrible so
I'm just I know I'll just have been
but this is my message to you I just want
you to keep your pecker up
and
the missionaries from California and and an
Idaho and Utah we were all Americans and to
the term pecker had a totally different
meeting we will call each other Peckerwood
in high school yeah Peckerwood you know we
had like anatolius we had no idea what he
was saying to the fact that it's like you
know if he'd send his zebra so you know the
other weird-ass English things that they say
over there right but so we just looked at
each other and my mission companion
companion the companion of my friend of mine
who was also had his own, he was the mascot
for Ricks college and university and he was
just a blazing red head you know Irish
wonderful do just so much fun. Me how to eat
salsa with a 7 never had salsa in my life
until I was twenty and
and I was on my mission it I had to go on
1990 to go on my mission to taste my first
salsa that's how white bread I was and and
if in the city so anyway so yeah he he we
just we were busting out laughing we were
like trying our hardest to like not much
just like laugh in his face and he was
trying you trying to get your ass up you did
a good job
I don't think that's what he meant to do
just keep your pick us up I'm like okay
does that mean we should
does that mean we should we should knock on
more of the doors when they come to the door
completely half-naked cuz we're in the
Caribbean does that mean we should go to
more baptisms on the nude beaches where they
roll their top down and they have those
beautiful blonde and black streaks in their
hair and white and I are blue eyes
what a memory keep it back up mate
dude this behavior of God like a fire just
look at the look up do not look up do not
look up that's not the spirit you're feeling
right now I promise
the spirits is not centralized in your pants
she's one of the inspector going to get a
send nineteen-year-old it's in the men at
their horniest time of their lives out into
the world to become missionaries and and
they like send them to a Beaches they sent
it to Martinique on French beaches where
nobody wears almost any clothing and then
they say Hey you can only have baptisms on
the beach and then we going to the beach
which I just have to find one that doesn't
have a bunch of naked beautiful French woman
on it
I was fucking torture going going back at it
it was wonderful torture it was wonderful
torture
many a missionary fell to the sins of the
Flesh in the Caribbean I'm just going to
tell you that right now I happen to know
because I was assistant to the president
which meant that I had to advocate for the
elders that had their crotches grab them
while they were presenting his field trip
with Joseph Smith's first Vision no kidding
or or the district is District Authority who
answered the door in the girl with the
fishnet top on with her very bucks in this
like hanging out said hey how can I help you
others and we were like dude I'm telling you
at every corner and then you are American
love times in American that means it was
ticket to wealth and lot of a lot of at
least four Elders that I knew married Martin
naked women that then went back to America
yeah I didn't have these like closet
relationships with everybody you know
and do stuff that's crazy
who's insane
I'll have to say about that is it was
exciting
is very exciting
wow alright what are we doing wait words
I think it worked omigod oh my God oh my God
Hocus Pocus focus Rob
focus focus focus focus I can't focus
I'd say let's do this let's do vagrants
SSH Dash C and then we're going to do
now we're going to do
are we doing now or doing
is a staged scarf disc Dash LS
Dash l and let's do that to control
God damn it we mean it's not
a weight control Dash see this
Machinery share fan we didn't get to pick
where we got to go by the way that was like
totally random you know
permission denied fuck you
does that say stabb
oh I know it doesn't damn it
it didn't work don't we didn't it didn't
work
Edwards and word doctor Professor Edwards
it worked it allocated a new disc drive holy
shnikies wait we wait
more booze plays cheers it was because of
you Doctor Professor we're good you were
good you're good luck
all right let's do this
let's do Vigor SSH into control
imma show you why I'm so happy
imma show you because watch lsblk
yes do you see it do you see it behold the
greatness there is an IDE controller device
that is the default and there's an extra 20
gig this weekend is signed it and if us
aren't you excited
tell me you're not excited
Jerry idea how long I've been trying to do
that all day all right so fine
yes and as much as labor going to be
this isn't even allocated just here this is
like
I'm trying to say is actually it should be
only I'll get it there so we got an old one
it should be omitted and so would you be
okay with all the blocked devices you know
that means we can mount it volume fill that
shit up with all kinds of shit and probably
just smelled like a 1-gig want to know that
I got the phone because I just want to fill
a fuck her fill it up when I fill it up and
break it yeah hey you know how to do that
much and me not like that you know but that
probably right if it's / m e space
I am super happy I mean I cannot be happy
right now and
the relatively minor thing
what I did is I use vagrant to provision
three machines virtual machines in including
one that has an extra amount point and
external volume that I can then attach the
NFS storage to provide an FS storage
so yeah
alright so let's see here I was at
show you a trick I don't need to USB trick
it's irrelevant it is much cooler look at
this actually created a disk drive ya on the
play called virtualbox this major one minor
or whatever
and I stayed within the scope of the
provider so it was something like extra shit
that had to happen
this is like really tremendous
now what now we need to make it if it's
mailed out of it which I've never done and
if I do that I will like be the happiest
person on planet Earth
I'm not exaggerating so they going up we did
it
wait so this is hands-down the best tutorial
on that
make sure to use IDE controller when working
with Linux
yeah oh my God
all right
I think this is a minor when I almost feel
like I want to leave it to me but I feel
like should we go all the way for the NFS
should we go all the way for the NFS Mount I
feel like the NFS Mount is like right around
the corner
oh my God
all right I should we go for it
which one you want to screw up on well this
is done this before I was like done
I need use F2 if using about Ellis Ellis
Ellis Bill game
yep
oh my God I'm so happy I learned a lot more
things to sew Zetas create
virtualbox and vagrant provider
uses sub commands
it might be obvious to everyone else but it
wasn't to me
when you see the following I it is the sub
command
to the main VB wasn't vbox
was it VB
to get to the main device management in
all right so I mean let me see what I mean
vagrants vagrant
as well as her if
tututututututu poppity pop Batman Grandy's
2 3 4 5 6 four five six seven eight
Apes
yep
alright so
so in the above
create HD is actually a box
create HD
and yes you have to fucking include the
proper case
that is a thing
setlist
I have feel like Star Trek I like a novice
like Newton yes
set edits vagrants how many vigorous I have
I'm going to delete that
Aaron's lighting they can even bring about
adding a second ride with me for a few bucks
learning lab
local cue
242 ignorance is a
usually the fastest way to get
a virtual environment running that allows
you to test
everything related
2 creating and on from Trinity's coaster
from scratch
related
I have to put stuff in my eyes that
otherwise I won't every time I'm going to
get repo I'm putting in my side as well so
pops up on those search results that's the
main reason I'm doing this
because I put that remain there as well. Lab
is it called
yeah
can this be the what what to drink less
try to keep her lettuce you know doctor
Professor since your insecurities I have to
do the community certified Security
administrator and the keynote of Def con
this year was how to break into communities
clusters using using all of its
vulnerabilities so as somebody interested in
forensics the security I think you might be
interested in that that's something I
haven't gotten to yet so I'm still trying to
get a handle on this occasion stuff to get a
certified administrator and developer stuff
but at some point we're going to move over
into hey we need to break into this thing
they're signing challenge or sign-in
challenge did they really I feel like that's
selling out man
seriously I feel like that's majorly selling
out
I'm not to talk to Bob about that Bob works
over there these days I've seriously
considered working there actually
hey I've been I've been asked apply
I've been asked if I had the box is Bob's
over there till 10 Bob is it works over
there I stated that he was telling about his
trip I need to go out for drinks with him
and have him just tell me everything about
it he went he went to Greece for a company
get together for have the box I was like oh
my God I want to join this company
Sonic.exe of activities America going to be
able to hack the shit out of many
communities cluster ever and that's part of
the fun I agree I feel like that's kind of
selling out I know why they did it I can say
I can assess I can probably guess why they
did it
doesn't make it any less you know the fun
vti
all right we're at we don't want to say that
20 GB of disk space to 2 to get home that
would be bad
I definitely practice absolutely
I know that's why I'm I'm kind of bummed too
but they removed it I liked it it took me a
long time since she was relatively simple
but I still think you're well
the river because the kid teacher anything
if you if they required to know something
before you can even get in
also try Acme trackers like very welcoming
and get overly marketed and you know he's
not nearly as good as active box not even
close but it's the thing that everybody
talks about
do do do do to do to do to do to do to do to
do
tell him I left the building and I know
where tell me why is
yeah
to do to do to do to do to teeth
I agree that it is more of a yeah they try
to do it but yeah
now they cannot remember his all going to
see when I'm typing
do you guys know what I am watching another
stream the whole time obviously but it's
like super Tuesday
alright so
so
all right so what are we doing here at we
got
we're going to take me to see it at first we
just need to
we just need to do NFS so we dive into NFS
right now or do we not do we like go ahead
and dive in and we wait I think we should
probably dive into n f s
yeah
alright so what we got here
alright I'm already relaxed you confess I'm
watching Leslie Leslie is fucking amazing
her stream is so much fun and she's doing a
bunch of amazing stuff with ripped she's
like they're doing a bunch of remote stuff
but her whole family is really fun to watch
she still got their dogs and their brothers
and sisters and cats and everybody over
there and the family is coming on his cell
phone. They're gone so go to subtil Leslie
she's really funny her full family's really
funny it's it's mostly a matter of
subscribing to their family and and it's
just like the central character in the whole
thing she's really crazy fun and she's also
learning coding so and she's doing IRL
streaming so it's just one big happy family
over here you know
I have an offense even if it's working this
kind of finish should we leave benefits for
now sweet even if this I think we should be
done if that's what you guys think
I think we should probably leave nfs4 now I
go for that
sweetie very festive tomorrow and play some
Dota or some Witcher
if I send out our son Witcher I think that's
probably the way to go
cuz I certainly can't concentrate anymore as
my second Brandy
did I make it straight says noon
but this is so great about this is I know
for a fact we can do any Fest know I
absolutely know that we can
so so here we go
alright so
I should probably save this anyway right
status get diff
you had more than a pretty fancy I'm still
working it's your you know it's pretty
obvious
no offense offense that's a bummer Peach
they call it right I don't know why they're
giving bomber credit for this I mean why is
he the one getting credit
so so yeah
I cannot get anything when I'm trash and it
makes me a better Tacker and know it's true
I strike totally agree there's something you
know why if you're if you're like me in your
life to anal and too tight about everything
Simpsons I need to be relaxed
most of the time he's been so romantic so
I'm either up or down right
yeah brother I mean it sounds as I'm saying
you probably you probably got it for some I
tried one yeah sometimes that energy drink a
pull me up I used to be addicted to the Red
Bull my God it was totally addicted
I was totally addicted I just could not look
away
Kenny's logic welcome
welcome to the crazy over here Kenny's logic
if you are the same kindness logic that I
think you are you're very welcome to be here
be aware that I will say the word fuck
randomly sell this is not your normal redigi
educational stream Pandora is it still sick
but it's a lot of crazy amazing awesome
things happening here if you wanted me to
speak English before I abandon it yes you
were I just I have to remain as long as you
you had to click okay they're right because
this is not still sick this is me unfiltered
Rob so so yeah
For Better or Worse
I can't use logic to go can you stream dude
in your gender I'm sorry
seriously you totally need to stream that
phaser gave me made you fucking need to I'm
sorry I'm sorry but you need to stream that
you need to see that you have any people is
seriously do you know how many people would
love to just know the basic stuff that you
did that you figured out to make that game
do you have it right now do you have it is a
public
Kenny's Logical Song that he just took the
space of game development and just ran with
it man he made a tank game it was like out
of control
yeah you have it you have it available I'd
love to show him
Kisame is wondering Cantonese logic used to
be one of the people that was in my mentor
community in person I used to measure him in
person
yeah yeah
so
I see that's where the other two came from I
heard I heard that it came from that but I
don't have room enough for that I I I I do
not have proof of that oh my God you put on
why you're so cool I'm so proud I am so I'm
so proud to say that I was at I was at least
as a minor factor in your learning how to do
all this shit
I got some gas I got some lineup issues
there this is where that's okay though
you'll get it you'll figure it out though
there's the April project
and you deserve a project yeah you did Evil
Freddy the stuff here oh my God
so I can t logic was in was it was it was
also in the class when I press when I talked
about the private school in this is a
project we did with a private school
yeah I taught in a private school for a
while and
I mean he was there so
about me and is the first one place we were
going through a phase is back on meeting at
the fire and get us collapsed a little
learning still sack race to learn stuff
yay God damn this makes me happy yeah
if you're sitting now it looks fine and it's
fine but you might want to try it on
different computers
certificates that's how you spell it. It's
okay though all right let's see here let's
go to projects games
platformer
oh my God you ain't totally went with the
Game Day game holy cow
yeah yeah yeah I know you're I got to stream
with 47 people on Twitch forever
seriously I'm like any Chinese letter you
should you should strip if you can if you
can you should stream how you made these
things and suffering game development on
Twitch you have any people there's like so
many people are trying to figure out how to
do basic phaser game development there
trying to figure it out have no idea I bet
you if you stream that they would lie would
watch it and when I do I remember making
these tanks this is a hard part right here
oh my God you play volleyball in the middle
that is
that is so cool what dreaded multiple Maps
although this makes me miss it so bad
oh my God that is so cool that is so cool
you like this this this just warms my heart
because it actually makes me miss it
the sexy miss it big time oh my God you have
different take think we should oh my God
this is so cool
I got to do one we had one V one some of
those two got to pick a tank right is it one
of you find did you actually figure out if
you owe you one
oh my God Tetra Tech has been chosen to take
as a chosen start
that I like we'll get it online don't worry
this is really easy right now boom wait how
do I shoot
oh no no this is it this is it to this is
yeah this is like the the the two player
same keyboard game right
yeah we did two player same keyboard on this
yeah I remember we did it because he didn't
want to do the networking stuff so this is
like this is like you can play us against
another person wait wait my shift and b i o
God
so much fun
oh I love it I love it already says it's
okay I think I messed up I think I'm going
to put her on accident all right if I get
yourself here yet I'm going to get I'm going
to shoot myself
what is it dinner what how do I shoot Escape
Asurion
it's dude it's a fun game it's like we had
we had to do games without networking guys
and this is their first game ever ever so so
they had to do it without now working
because we didn't Network he's not too hard
but you gotta understand this is like
they're like literally there first thing
ever
wait you died
is pretty fun it's pretty fun this is really
great I will power up here
check out the lion level you have debug mode
haven't changed my mode on
how to turn you back what's Civic mode how
do I turn it on like for something
jitterbug
inspects or yes inspect Source console
elements
18 once I was also eyes of God
sources let me go in here scene 1
Super Bowl preload
oh my God this is so cool you like multiple
things in here to don't you but here you go
look at you go
it is a truth that's why I got the assets
all I got is so cool
that's so cool it's been a great night
that's all I have to say
I mean cut this stuff
what am I committing get there if I don't
want to lose you before I forget
commit hey how's it going Jeremy
yeah you don't talk about right get push
commit add
and secondary disc to control for an FS
later
get pushed so anybody who wants to follow
along in this lab
this is the one this is my lab that I did
related to cover days and vagrant
new communities in vagrant if you want to
follow along with that Kenny logic thanks so
much for the link to that that's really fun
I am very serious I would love to see you
stream I kind of feel sad because I wanted
to like help people start their own streams
at school sick so he's coming back we are
going to start cutie she still stuck again
for free on beginning of May 4th
and I'm going to I'm going to make a book
about it
so so this is the schedule so May 4th the
three weeks of summer we will be teaching
the beginner Blues which is
beginner boost on May 4th is design for
absolute beginners
and will be the same content essentially
that I wouldn't be teaching in skill SEC if
I were teaching in person but I'm no longer
doing it in person lots of changed actually
lots of changed its really important we
understand containers as well as Lennox in a
bunch of things like that so that's coming
we're doing see coating we've been working
from the book head-first see if you want to
learn how to make games and see what could
be making asteroids if we make it in time we
only have one more week then I'm going to
make it so
you got something serious for me mister
doctor professor
all right if you say so I'm going to go
ahead and play a game or two
full to do to do to a page
yeah I think I R C
yep all right
this is between us this hard yeah
everything about hacking into my machine and
that's it everything
yes it is yes it is yes yes yes please
yep and on that note I'm going to go ahead
and relax
terminal I mean your terminal will pull to a
site
yes please send me whatever you can send me
if you hacked my system I want to know in
anyway I mean I have hardening I need to do
so and certain things
Eric Bolling photo site what are you doing
are you doing I just didn't get graphics
are you just doing are you just in graphics
am i t t y
yeah I'm pretty sure you can find my pee if
you need to I know just just let me know
did you buy Rite
and everybody saw me type that so that's not
a secret cuz it affected with those keys on
turn to a window so others can scroll up
oh okay yeah are you talking about just
inferring the TTY from the screen and the
graphics on the screen what if you found
something like that that's fucking amazing
I mean how else can you get a TTY input
control a
yeah our team has a short image results time
I used to do anyway
oh okay
yeah it might be a bit different
I don't know who to raid
I feel like I feel like I need to go I'm
going to go and take a break and just come
back and play. I don't care I mean to stream
none of it's going to YouTube so I don't
care if it's like a an infinite stream of
uselessness and when I come back I'm going
to I'm going to stay away
I'm awayI'm away and wait for now
and I'm going to I'm going to stand up and
go take a break tomorrow for sure and and
over the weekend we're going to be doing
again I'm going to continue to work on work
stuff through the weekend and that's how I
operate I'm just kind of blow to the lines
between work and other stuff but we do need
to work on and internal messaging method and
I'm going to be doing that so
so yeah I'm putting away on my way a message
on for now I'm put some fishes on for y'all
how much are my thing here
and hopefully you don't go for go have fun
go to take a break Go Get It Go Get Some
Randy whenever
talk to you in a bit by
dog is crazy
got it I got you
I got
got you
little girl that makes her mad
Jersey City gets so mad
has a workout
she wants you and Sam send me one but I
still get the price
you should see her look at me like I want
the fries
is my price
for what for projectors
oh I have I have tons of different stuff
you're tired too huh
you should see her look at her she's like
panting Hi Sam
say hi
planning on Santee today how am I going to
get his plushie when he's not looking
when he's not looking how am I going to get
it I tired her out
I successfully tired her out oh shit sorry
about that Sam
honey they're coming over here where it's
safe
you're crazy
black dog and under that room
oh my God that is so tiring and Salerno I
have them super tired
super tired so she I tired her out
successfully
this is the prize her hair
hey go honey you one yes you did
yeah
Hiawatha can you get lots of things ice and
a fancy or set up with crazy ass lights and
all that stuff and it's like bolide horribly
lid room is still better
cuz you know why cuz I actually stream Rowan
stream pieces like too much of a pain in the
ass
what shall we do trying to find out if
Master Gtech yes I'm going to ask everybody
Way by playing today
I don't have to I'm sure you didn't follow
me to play DotA
ocean
this is like I'm changing my status of
people psych fair warning people can go away
did you know when you change your category
that it gives you a separate title
did you separate chapter and twitch yes,
it's kind of cool yes, it's kind of cool
think
hey Google Play My turbosound Nature's
prophet
got to go he look at my vasyl see that
there's multiple chapters every time I
change the category changes the chapter
so the moral of the story is if you need to
change if you want to like make a break
between different things you doing in
science a deck switch to just chatting and
then switch back and then that'll make you a
chapter in your life stream
if you want one or something like that
horses bsrfc I like if you want to if I want
to do is tomorrow for a bit and then
exactly exact the mall
pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom
Dota 2
Wisconsin line find match
the fastest comes through shall we
my what's all this what's all this
oh God
I spend some money can we I never spend
money on time
Legacy premium
hey look free code Camp is teaching
kubernetes in 3 hours
I'm sure that's fine
but freecodecamp just publish this guy to
the official certified kubernetes
administrator exam this will help you decide
whether to serve acacian is worth the effort
somebody's been watching the artifacts wrong
wait do I have them stop running
I think I do I think I do god dammit
kids
my pron tab oh I have lots of fun
I was probably talking about
which which prawn
do do do do do do Botanicals by Kelly not
into tentacles
nope cannot say that I am allergist Philly
I can't find interest in that
isn't it great I seriously I fall I stomped
all four games they played last night and
tonight I probably won't win a single one
just cuz I'm sure drunk
but we shall see
where are you mr. fury on there you are go
get him dude whatever you are
hey where you going
in the scary in the jungle their Nations
profit or your Nature's prophet
free dram content absolutely
I already got it and damn it we are going to
meet me at this is awesome
this is beyond awesome I feel good things
coming
damn it and miss miss the missing still
god dammit
god dammit my license are sucking
god dammit my kids are horrible today
Dawn is your towel or time for me to
dominate
to to do
all right now what
it takes a while I mean it's kind of hard to
learn right off the bat
imma need to regroup
I can play you can talk to me I'm just
mistakes and I don't always answer because
I know focusing but
xcode for streaming
everything about Mac apps and stuff yeah I
don't use that for much
elbow is mine baby
excites
no not really I mean you know just the
basics HTML and CSS and it's kind of figure
it out when you know all the waste as you
know host it and everything already
so
I had to go Greg you always come when I'm
playing. I do you like wait for me to change
the topic
I spent all day dealingI spent the whole day
doing covid-19
is it come for the donut I know are you nice
and me too
okay
the skill second we're not doing local skill
s going to be online so I can to be until
May 4th
bedtime he basically the same content
yeah to go read the Boost content it's it's
the same for people that are a little bit
older I told her up you know
but yeah and we're going to be doing
anything with games it's all terminal-based
stuff I mean that's why I mean there's lots
of fun things to do with games right but
as a mature now
Python and Swift as languages
I need a B on his school are there python or
Java in school
just curious
yeah
yeah our doctor I would suggest talking to
that would be my
preference
now he's God's not well it depends on what
you're doing. Webdav on this after doing now
makes a lot of sense
2 2 2 2 2 2 2
xcode yeah X's a Mac only thing but I see
why you could be attracted to it
did you do do do do do do do do do do do do
do
God damn I can't even have a chance to kill
anybody we stomped him so hard
God damn this is a Stomp
this is my favorite go-to and which are
which are my favorite active 2
easy as pie my God this gamemy God this game
was so easy
his build is stomp so bad this Nature's
probably bill just really really Stomps
it's crazy actually published it and publish
this build so other people can stop if they
want
his search for addiction on on Dakota for
guides if you want to play the guide
yeah
backlinks click ass click. Clink toss Bowl
and that's Connecticut men's all-around game
have a great game
did we didn't even get that many kills and
we still destroyed
I got to stream what games I play I play I
play with your Witcher 3 in Dota 2 and see
if 2 and Minecraft you as well
I don't play a lot of games but when I do I
play those are the ones I play
I'm not on a pretty much a casual and
everything I do just cuz it's fun
but I enjoy it this dog I tired this dog out
man
Hades dog she's totally tired now
she saw me drop the killer money I dropped
the killer money and she was like what's
this shows came and got it
yeah I just tired her out we just had a big
game of tug-of-war and now she's like
exhausted
get a good workout
I'm going to stomp with MP again this build
is like insane so far I have never lost with
this build
they demanded they know me they know me is
not the new Crystal
Havana cuz they know me that is yes it is
oh shit
didn't lock it in god dammit I want to go
because I was too much
Nimble your bum niblet what's it going to do
when you be a bum
bring in the Holy Hand Grenade of Antioch
p please show me the number that we shall
count
5 is right out
yep what time is it
and I feel I feel bad time calling me I'm
going to go to bed and I'll be up at like 3
again like I always do
I'm trying to break that but not doing too
good a job
we're going to probably lose this but I'm
going to stay positive
cuz I'm Crystal crystals fun
quetzal spawn but she's kind of dangerous
the reason I really want to pick a kiss
Krystal by the way is if you have a really
Mana heavy team and I actually do have them
on a heavy team if you have a Mana heavy
Team crystals Arcana can tilt the game all
by itself
all by itself because it gives everybody
everybody gets
it is extra to Mana regen early game and
that can tilt tilt the early game if they
know how to play
I don't know how to play
we held tight with Russell we went 40
minutes and turbo and I held off the thing
cuz I kept holding everybody
it was so funny they could not get in they
cannot break in
God damn it now I'm going to feed
you know why cuz I missed I hit tab instead
of Q otherwise I would had that killed
yeah when your marriage is also here by
default absolutely
yeah
call Cathy Socha na I'll tell you how it's
so it's no it's such now it's searching out
because of torch now it's touching
associative
Godzilla the song
that's how I should have killed slark if I
hadn't hit tab instead of Q because of my
shity Turbo skills
hey that's called The dietitian wondering
you think you're going to get me he think so
but he does not know me
that's right that's right mr. Sark that's me
killing you just in case you're wondering
that's me killing you sark
I should have done that and got first blood
but I hit the Tab Key instead of the q key
cuz I'm an idiot
God grant us all
oh boy looks like we're getting on dated
we're getting on did
who is giving up all those kills by the way
had to take over mid
December spirit is not not inspiring
confidence which I always say
dudududu dudududu
I'm also playing the suicide line which is
super fucking dangerous
I'm going straight for the big guns straight
for the big guns people
Conn's at the swords now
I saw her to get last chance with her hey I
did it I did it again
I did it again why so proud I got three
glasses with Crystal
this dog is going insane right now
she must have barely had a rest now she's
like wrestling on the ground like a silly.
You're so silly you are you're silly you
want to play again seriously you had to rest
and oh my God she's putting the thing on
I'm out of here I'm out of here you can't
kill me tell him I kill you first
when can you first
come on come on to our divers Tower divers
Unite
and I tell her neighbors United die
dog wash station I tried I'll do it again
you from him
call Jed that's all. I'll tell you had sosna
it's very search now
I don't know what's up with this game I
really don't it's kind of a weird game
Miss December is an idiot
come on
come on Amber you didn't even right click
him on you dude you can go die December does
not deserve mid
I refuse to get December mid is fucking
feeding the whole time
I don't have I don't have one level lower
than him and he was mid
that's called the last two Denver
deny it
Snowden is a total Noob total noob is trolls
out fed
I'm not leaving I'm not leaving I don't care
I don't want him to feel anymore 61
seriously seriously who the fuck is feeding
God damn he's so fed
it was a stupid that's kind of troll
come on push the tower come on you can do it
you're a big bad troll come push that are my
friend
Porsche Tower yeah
God damn it that's only because you so
fucking fed how did he was stand my own like
that I know because he has three levels on
me
yeah this guy fed the shit out of the stroll
and now
pudges absolutely retarded oh well
oh well it was turbo who cares why you think
I play Turbo
watching that email to finish that
that would be a double kill for me that
would be a double kill just kiss Emma is
wondering
yeah no shit you're getting mulched
cuz you suck
it's okay hey Cindy care it's nothing
personal I'm just stating facts
the first the first sign is like the lack of
denies unless it's it's usually the first
sign of someone sucking
all right now they're all full of hubris
come on over here
at the Hyde at the Hyde
I'm hiding cuz they're going to go for the
tower I'm going to get a quick killing I got
to go for the tower
God damn I almost have
you suck that made me very happy
that made me very happy I have to admit I
have a couple of words no
what is this regular Dona expectations from
a supporter of the by words what the fuck is
wrong with you
no I'm going to buy
I just had to go to all those expectations
no longer fly I got banished
shit I'm done S I like coming I'm not
thinking these guys are so fed up fed they
are
I'm the highest on my team and I'm fucking
Crystal Maiden
it's like seriously this game is crazy
they haven't lost a single Tower they
haven't lost a single Tower
I have the most kills on my team tied with
which doctor
it would be funny if it wasn't so damn
pathetic I'm never going to need this
God I can't get there in time of God
I just bolted I just salted the base cuz I
pushed are in 70 do you have any times
that's the third time I've done that that is
the worst fail and all of DOTA for Crystal
Maiden I went to push tea instead and I
pushed our and I altered instead I blew my
old Freddy 3 seconds I could have got a
quick you'll but instead I altered my
ancient
so I'm not free from blame here I am
definitely not free from blame here
how easy was it to kill you
oh my God that guy's an idiot
I'm God remix River can bite me come on but
you can do it
oh great trolls killing me again
the FED troll who went mid versus this idiot
ever who continues to feed
kubernetes Man play DotA what's wrong with
that
no surprise there right unnecessary
complexity I like to suffer
I like to suffer with things that are over
the complex for no fucking reason
it's like I torture myself with it it's like
and then I'm dying
damn I lost my lead I lost my need somebody
pass me dammit punch finally passed me
my stats I was leaving the whole game and
tell her I altered the ancient
they have a lots of fucking Tower we won
yesterday we want in 12 minutes and they
didn't get any Towers either was hilarious
Barcelona cool down
Australia physical damage it's so much more
fun to attack really fast. I got to tell you
it's just so hilarious did I can hold I can
on this ancient like all day
that's why I need that's why I need me KB I
even gave you the stop getting me like that
I did not get that killed God damn it
2 2 2 2 2
I just kind of cyst on that that sucks I
should I kill 338 seconds
3 seconds to old-time you know what I need I
need
I need for staff I'll give you a b and then
I get for sale
where's that battery TV mine
why would you do that you're not going to go
check him
I going to die that pair comes
now I'm going to die hey nice I decided to
follow my team down to the danger zone and
then I died
and then they're all going to feed now too
hahaha like it's turbo dude
why I'm fly isn't in fly some of my age OK a
10 that's not weird
want to play a true Carrie cuz mine is
boring
I can play like Legion or anyting but it's
more fun if I Crystal and Greg at the
Queen's gaels and turbo
here I come to save the day you don't need
you now
I need for Stuff
here we go here we go
double kill for me double kill for me
like oh shit
it's raining for Stafford here I can't fight
against that guy so I have to get out of
there
Force F where the fuck is for staff
yes please
oh I know you can leave around 2 it's like
so great yes this is true
yeah why don't you buy something dumbasses
oh nice tripod that's pretty damn close
I am so mad that I didn't get the
fast-attack stuff
I should have got that instead I got a reply
back
at McAllen for me cuz they like me they like
me they're my friends stay on High Ground
stay on
stay on High Ground stay on High Ground stay
out up there they go
stay on High Ground I'm waiting I'm going to
be Last Resort dude
yeah
you know what you can do that all you want
that's just stupid
I'm like the last resort baby
they're going to split attack that's kind of
smart they're attacking from all sides
that's actually really smart I that's I'm
impressed
most of times I'll just come in at once and
die
God damn it really
yeah bring it on in here
seriously I can't protect against that shit
I can't
dead head
did
do do do do do do do do do to I had the most
kills in the whole game yay me also I didn't
feed 11 debts
headed to finance a face rag
yes Enigma I like Enigma but I don't plan to
an English one of the coolest heroes in the
whole game in my opinion
Enigma has been responsible for more four
more wins at the international level than
any other thing
yeah are mid got 011 against roll I wonder
what happened why did we lose most of cuz if
not I lost it and deny so troll got fed
that's how come
if they did I don't I don't regret it I
don't regret playing it for a second this
one
it's fine I'm stopping at my Nature's people
know me though they know me in my region
when I play the J band Nature's immediately
do do do do do do do do do do
sometime you'll get a drink drink I got
yeah you know we have a bad game one when
Crystal Maiden has the most kills also the
most gold
and I'll bet you anything that nobody else
has lost its when you met me you want to bet
me
and yet you know how you know they could go
in the good players and DotA
is this this is the fastest way to assess
identify a good player from an idiot
and I already knew what they were going to
call it
refreshing was Lincoln the name oh my God
yeah I wish I could do that I don't play
that way I wish I could is the fastest way
to establish a good player you look at the
ones you don't have any denies
if they have zero denies then you know
they're an idiot that's how you know
what's the fastest way to identify an idiot
and brand new person and go to and then you
remember their name and then
their name and then you remember when you're
going to play them cuz you going to be with
them again in the region probably wonderful
human beings but then you just know what
you're doing with the you like okay now I
know what I'm dealing with
I don't recognize anybody from here but they
recognized me because my name is pretty
recognizable
I've had one person actually like watching
me on string whole time to see where I was
wait to see how you can do that right that's
why people delay streams on Twitch I'm like
if you going to do that in Turbo okay fine
if you need that to feel good about yourself
I'll give you that triple sevens retirement
777 esta means something it must mean
something greater than me
seriously this troll just dominated mid can
you tell who trolled fight against can you
tell I'll tell you who there you go
Nana's river guy owned acerbic time so I got
this though
watch residual Amber 6 skills he told me 5
times and that's bad that's definitely bad
he picked on me
6 holes on a mid early game I was even worse
22 total
either they don't type or speak
I see what you mean I see what you mean I
don't know if I agree you're talking about
because I cannot pubs yet
are we talking about pubs for sure but
yeah if you plan on the team course you
wanted to talk see like band again cuz they
are telling you they know me
they know if he could you play play against
know me they know that I ripped them in the
fucking do it I went 14 and 0 yesterday and
one of my Four Winds yesterday every game I
played yesterday one with with this and I
just wanted to know they know they started
that should we try that but stay and chat is
like really fucking fun and chant is so much
fun especially if your new boo we can't go
cuz they're Stones you can't play enchant
versus tonnage is bad for enchant ice
probably lose you but I don't want to
I want to play Legion it's too dangerous I
know I'll play Ricky Ricky goddamnit the
band all my fun trolling Heroes
fine fine
he's Mele
oh ranged melee melee melee arranged so I
can find at the rate the range guys
oh good yeah razor can back me up that's
good
it's so hard to play Legion without arranged
in your lane
because she gets gets ripped to shreds by
and write any range Heroes thank you music
music is nice
the job stuff
is a tough one because this one is good for
Less
I don't know what I'm going to do here I
don't want to do my try something different
I'm going to try something different with
him her whatever she is
yeah I think we were straight straight
I'm going to go straight to travel boots
I have a good feeling about this razor I do
I have a good feeling about this razor
I don't like this build I'm going to play
thisit's Bill. I'm going to pay this bill
differently we'll see
if I liked her as she does need Foods kind
of
hey Tap Rock
I got a regen was afraid of this I was
afraid of this
start a play early game bottom line that's
fine I have a son yet
I do not want to feed kills early game
that's like really stupid
his razors got my back you could actually
pull the set together
oh my God that's the one hit
guys nice razor this razors good man I like
playing with this razor I'm not
I can be patient and pick up the stuff later
my text was too slow
nothing we're just hanging around to let you
know because I don't talk like I won't be
able support in juggle normally I would but
turbo doesn't work that way
I wish I was like that when is it happening
is end up getting too low
you get drunk off you still have enough
I can't I can't pick you up oh see this is
I'm going down
I'm going down I have a feeling I'm going
down Hastings MI verdad
treasure knows what's up. This is a good
razor it's really great razor
the jungle could give you more XP I think it
turbo I don't have that I used to used to be
that way
yeah it's a thing with Legion I don't I
don't want to die is the thing under a level
but the thing that they just you can pick up
the levels later I'm under a level pretty
bad
yeah I just I'm going to get I mean this
race was going to kick ass I'm going to
letkick ass I'm going to let the Razor Kick
Ass I probably get the reserve Lane even
I just come in and clean up for the duels
oh he's got himself careful careful
I was going to ask enough XP is good as good
XP
I don't really like Face Beats on her I
don't
I don't know if I'm going to get Chris or
attack speed we need to get a current tax
being probably
can I cancel my TV
such an idiot I'm such an idiot I get so
excited and then I cancel my TV I do it all
the time
I something is attack speed
I know I need to turn it on
I need to turn the heart cancel and I don't
know how to do that I had somebody told me
that the other day and I was like why the
fuck am I not doing that
that's an easy oh God maybe not I forgot
about the up there of course
god dammit I need to do hard cancel on GPS
I absolutely need to do that
spell certain
I ain't need to text me and I don't know how
to buy it how to get it fast
I don't know how to get a taxi the best
how do I get a taxi I got to text me before
I get this later
have to look at my my build
guess I just expensive I need to text me.
I mean regular please give you a text.
God damn I'm never there hello we doing
it's a bad time but I can I'm sorry I want
to see
get me out of here I really
she got some kind of know he was just hiding
I got to do all of it it's only 10
this is sloppy we're going to win it but I'm
just really sloppy
sloppy I'm telling razors kicking ass the
razor's playing really well
raising my buddy Sophia has a mama
don't kill him
they're all dead they're dead Jim
are they that ain't all
I need Sharde Sharde is kick-ass charger do
you spell immunity it's so cool
are canceled able to I need to figure that
out three reading my stuff
also I need faster attack speed what gives
attack speed on her probably a selkie R Us
I'm thinking I'm thinking of salt cure Asia
I'm not I'm not fighting in that
yeah that would have been a bad tool bad
Newell might not have died though
when I die three times I guess the
second-highest top-class deaths under the
worst player on the worst player
play Onyx yes if I got a bunch of shit going
on same time so
I need a stone bad
I have a troll noise I had a troll why are
you pushing me to our pleas for missionary
yes go go go go hit the tower
I guess they're not rats like me
against Manish yeah it's just fun
I think it's delightful wait
god dammit trial
shit there's a fight one round let's get to
the fight
we're destroying these guys no thanks to me
I'm taking it
I'm a tank it and careful we got canceled so
I guess they just don't want to fight fine I
was going to have to Stone
that would be my first phone are we
converging what are you doing here peoples
oh shit how is razor razor when you get a DL
has weird
all right here we go
come on people you gave him the win all
right I see how you are
you hate I mean come on that was not that
hard of a kill he's like no Health never
even fucking right clicked
supports a picture that was not my fault
I have to do on that was my my all they
didn't even notice single right click for my
entire team and they were all there
how is a $2 credit it was a little confusing
and meanwhile are they going to lose people
who do this like who wait who thinks that
they are just say we can lend us any time
I've beaten people like that all the time
because they wait and then it was just too
dangerous to do that
if you can still do that so easily because
they're all dead
so it's razor this RZR knows what's up I'm
not afraid of his rages on our team this
razor is good like really good
the Raiders good good razor
we win I think Sammy how's the worst on the
team but
I put a new someone I didn't give up tools
and shit like bad Legions do
man told youtold you they're good they are
I saw him under level buy a lot ship Melinda
Lowe
I can't say moles I'm okay just too many and
I'm playing good I'm not playing horribly
but I'm not playing it on the horse on the
team
worst on the team right now
am I doomed I think in Turbo I think there's
a support given to give it to rancheros
beans
in Elysian team than the last one in the
winter Chief a China vase
I kissed her I completely agree I have no I
like I feel shame because I sucked this game
I did I totally sucked I'm a horrible kind
of afraid to fight because I let razor take
all the hits I just I don't like playing
melee in Turbo
Millie and turbo is like just asking to get
your ass kicked because it's all that ranges
in Turbo in my opinion
cuz you're not you're not even close to them
to do the damage you know you're just so you
can lay down so much damage from a distance
and you still have like maneuverability
I I seriously I think I I think Raines
Heroes have a strong Advantage not to
mention they can get work at it or he'll
break or something and they can they can
meet you so you can even get on top of them
to do anything it's really hard to play
Amelie here on in in in Turbo my opinion
I mean s skeletons pretty forgiving I mean
leaves is pretty damn forgiving
crazy bastard yeah yeah it's better still
thing
yeah but I mean the thing is you have to get
to them when you plan to get strange cereals
like the reason the reason that the reason
that like dumbasses I don't have any High TV
butterfly be the reason that
the people and turbo kick sniper all the
time is exactly that reason he's like the
easiest right click hero you just stand back
and rack up the kills because because in
Turbo you get so much gold so quickly you
can buy all kinds of shit that make up for
the fact that that your ranged in your
squishy as a Ranchero so would you rather be
a male hero that does the same damage or
rain sure that does the same damage which
one would you rather be and that's why in
Turbo I think mainly Heroes and turbo is
really dangerous to put email he wrote all
the time but they're much harder to play in
Turbo in my opinion
so imma take a quick break
yeah I think I played him in the racial so I
think that's part of the reason my my timing
of last hits is really is really based on
Ray Charles ain't even even a chance I can
buy her better than most most my life
all right I'm going I'm going to watch a
show of my wife see you guys later bye